Hello, hello, hello!
Booy, booy, boee, booo!
Are you going to see the boy, ta-taba?
Hello, welcome b*** Hi everybody, hi, hi, hi, hi Hi, hi, hi,
hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi Howdy!
Hello, hello!
WelcomeUM To Barry's Barry, Barry's back?
We're... we're back.
How am I feeling?
Strange!
My cough is so much better now, which is crazy.
I've only been on the medicine one day.
And literally...
Okay, but I'm taking like...
Well, yesterday was like nine pills, and then I decrease
each day.
So today was...
Today, I haven't taken...
How many?
I take... I took...
seven oh yeah six so i don't know yeah nine pills it was
crazy yeah they give me the good stuff but like the one
medicine i'm on oh my god i'm looking at my hands now holy
i'm i'm shaking like crazy don't say it stop it stop it
right now mods ban that guys
I was bad bad bad them Mads Me Banned them Me though got the
roid rage Yeah Oh my god The the steroid is making me One of
the side effects is like Insomnia Which I had I got two
hours of sleep baby And then also I'm shaking like crazy I'm
like a little shaken baby Which don't do that but i'm like i
feel like i took like an ultra espresso i'm like crazy yeah
my muscles are growing you're gonna see me in like two days
and i'm just gonna be ripped my shirt wait wait wait wait
can you tell the difference
can you tell am i ripped am i ripped or am I huge gains on
my arms massive buff
as frick thank you thank you thank you yes strong as a stick
noodling we're noodling out here meant leaving the mid cafe
for the muscle girl bar i learned something about the muscle
girl bar because i wanted to go i was like oh i want to go
but apparently if you go and you're like shy to be on camera
they they live stream the entire store which is kind of
scary like on twitch like you can just go and you you you
are on the tv yeah isn't that I'm like kind of I'm like I
get it it's good for you know business to like get eyes on
you and everything but they live stream like the main stage
which if you are at the muscle girl bar you go to the main
stage to get like the fine cell or whatever the fan service
and then but also there's like a camera on the entire store
I haven't been before I didn't go You can't just say that
and not provide a link.
I don't know, Google, Google is free!
Hot dog!
Google!
What is that, what is that site?
Let me Google that for you.
It's on Twitch though, it's on Twitch.
Oh, oh, why am I big?
Oh my goodness.
Yeah.
Hello, Minto and I was like you!
I can't wait to bury some berries in this big hole with
Swole Minto.
Yeah!
I'm on steroids for lung stuff too.
Beefcake.
Woo!
We're beefing together.
What's our beef?
We're beefing.
We now have issues.
Abstract mode.
We're beefing.
Mickey Strong, Mickey Smash!
That's why I'm green.
I'm already hulking.
I'm hulking out.
That's why I'm green, baby.
My cat is on steroids.
It's funny.
I'm on the same exact medicine as my cat.
oh gosh now that i'm talking of course i start coughing but
yeah baby car thanks for the fun get there thank you thank
you thank you good morning marshaler marshaler marshaler i
know we're twinning mink it is real i'm on the same medicine
as my cat when when the doctor asked me they were like do
you know this medicine have you been on it before And I was
like, yes.
No.
Where do I know this from?
How do I know this medicine?
They probably were like, what's wrong with her?
She needs the strongest thing.
She doesn't even know.
I was like, how do I know this?
one whole year of me too thank you phil mint took her cats
meds yeah but he's on like a much smaller dose i think i
don't know if he took my dosage he might be like you know
with how crazy i am right now fries welcome back becoming a
cat for real for real providing inspiration for forever
Forever, meow I want to be forever, meow Do you really want
to meow forever?
Endeavor Forever, meow I want to be forever, meow I just got
it out of my head
Sorry, I think when I laugh I get the worst cough Actually,
that's like the worst it's been today I don't talk much when
I'm not streaming.
That's no good for stream.
Yeah, but the doctor didn't say that I can't stream.
Actually, they don't know what I do.
Does Min Kidi fart like her cat now, too?
Wrong cat, Ducky.
Oh, my gosh.
It's, it's, it's, it's, but that's on it.
Not, not pies.
she did rip a really bad one the other day though yo made
amazing stream as always and happy to be here too so it's my
birthday no happy birthday happy happy birthday so laughter
isn't the best medicine yeah and they also told us an apple
a day keeps the doctor away and i had like Before I got
sick, I had like 10 apples.
Almost as tall as me.
It's a lot of apples.
Did they all have worms?
Disgusting.
Extra protein?
Maybe?
An apple a day keeps the doctor away, but it doesn't keep a
waving toe.
If you have an apple, your kitchen right now I'm coming over
to eat it no way you're taller than ten whole apples I am
actually how tall is ten apples grok how tall is ten apples
Jarvis activate the Apple measurer last night I was at work
and I nearly responded customer's email with good morning
minto you are becoming minto i might have possessed you for
a second there sorry my bud we need lots of apples more
apples and more berries because we're playing berry berry
berry we gotta get more berries so that we can make our
whole huge uh i only have tangerines okay that's also
acceptable i do love me a tangerine but actually i just love
fruit Hello, Vito.
I'm really happy and proud.
I get to be a fan of you.
That is all.
What did I do?
What did I... What did I do?
Hmm?
I remember the last time you streamed this, we had to call
the sentences with this.
Yeah, that's right.
That's when YouTube chat broke and everyone became Japanese.
It's the weeaboo dream.
Yep, there's two.
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to, like, do a mega clear of my throat because I
feel like I've got something stuck in it.
Apples.
Though, I had a bag of apples that I was getting through
before my trip.
And I didn't finish it.
And I came back.
And I don't look any different.
How long are apples good for?
That kind of I was like, whoa.
Apples do last quite a while.
They do?
Zombie apples.
They can last a while actually.
Oh, really?
No, they weren't refrigerated.
I was gone for like a month.
Actually, they're like older than that because I got them
before I even left.
Over a week.
What about a month?
wax covering it must be always wash your apples actually i'm
so paranoid because when i when i eat raspberries why do
they have a hole in them you know they have a hole in them
and then little bugs and spiders can crawl in there and hide
it's terrifying i always look in the hole are you sure they
aren't plastic oh man did i buy model apples again the berry
hole yeah i look in berry's hole big hole is love big hole
is life feel better thank you i'm sorry i'm already feeling
a lot better the medicine it's crazy how it started working
hold on sorry oh my gosh it started working like day first
day is so crazy but i don't know i'm feeling After this past
month, being, I'm going to be honest with you guys, being
sick twice and the workload of everything that happened in
Japan, I'm like, honestly, I'm like, man, I think I'm
actually feeling the signs of a burnt out.
I feel so bad, too, because, like, obviously, when I was
gone, I didn't get to stream so much.
But there was so much happening, and I was so sick and so
stressed with everything.
I was like, man, I think, I think I'll have a vacation soon.
I booze were worried.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean to...
Now why am I falling apart?
I didn't mean to worry, you guys.
So maybe I'll take, like, a small, small, small break.
Like, not even, like, like a week or something.
You know what I mean?
Um...
So, that will be coming up rather soon.
Yeah.
Yeah, just a week to kind of reset.
Take a month off.
No, I just did that, basically.
Evisible Moose, thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
And I don't want to take it off for streaming.
I just kind of need to reset my mental a little bit after
the stress of all the sickness and all the work.
I know that I wasn't streaming much during all the sickness
and all the work so I'm really sorry but please thank you
for your patience and everything I'll come back and I'll be
nice and refreshed and nice and excitable so um but I love
you know I love streaming so it's not like it's a chore or
work for me um I'll probably miss it more when I take the
small break but I just need the kind of the time to like you
know sleep Here's to the Mickey vacation, but no, thank you
though, thank you.
Just himself, thank you so much for the thank you.
Thank you.
We know how busy you've been, take your vacation as an
actual vacation, please.
I will, I will, I will, thank you.
Yeah, just a bit of a factory reset.
But it won't be so long.
Like I said, just a week or so.
Yeah, yeah.
Tomodachi Life is in two weeks, a perfect comeback stream.
I gotta play the demo.
I wanna make like ultimate drama island.
Wait, that's a TV show, isn't it?
I wanna have like a messy, messy island.
That's total drama island.
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One year!
Take a year break.
Oh my gosh.
I would probably combust.
Sensei, welcome to me.
Mavusha, thank you!
Loving your Oshi means wanting them happy and healthy.
I am happy!
I just need a bit of a...
Like, I just need to conk out.
I need someone to hit me over the head and have me into a
week-long coma or something.
You know?
Hikari-kuo, welcome back!
Thank you!
Yeah, bonk, bonk, bonk!
Allow me, queen?
Okay.
no i need the violence i need the violence i don't need that
long extreme violence youtube don't look it's gonna get
messy the mint chicken it's uh kind of sound like I was
saying.
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
Yeah.
Have a good rest, Minto.
For real, I hope.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
She said extreme violins.
Oh, yeah.
I wish I still had my violin.
You know, I was first chair.
I was...
A professional.
I wasn't professional.
But, yeah.
I was pretty good.
I was decent.
I was decent at violin.
I've been kicking heavy bags for 14 of the past.
24 out of 14?
I would be honored to Leon Kennedy kick for some guaranteed
rest.
Okay, one thing that I did.
Okay, this might be controversial.
I want you guys' opinion.
As a non...
As a person that has only played a single Resident Evil
game, and that was the co-op.
While I was sick, I watched somebody play a playthrough of
Requiem.
I was like, I don't think I'm ever, you know, if I get
through the games, that would be great, and then I can play
Requiem again, and hopefully better appreciate everything.
Because I was like, okay, I was like, what?
I don't want anyone to ever say that MGS4 is a bad storyline
ever again because I was like
the game is the exact first of all it's the exact same game
MGS4 and Resident Evil died or the exact same game
okay what my thoughts on it is I really okay this might be
controversial I like that they the survival horror game part
with grace's part and then the action with leon um wait am i
missing a birthday nah well thank you so much for the vibe
gifted that's like starting mgs with four rising only sickos
do that hello fellow two hours of sleep warrior i turned
another herald today can you give me can you like can you
give yourself a pat on the back and one compliment consider
a birthday gift from us we're always proud of you man happy
birthday Hi!
Pat on the back.
Ow.
And compliment.
I brush my hair today.
Good job, me.
And Royed-powered Pat.
I can't help it.
I'm too strong now.
I could probably lift every single one of you at once.
Everyone here.
Get on my back.
But anyway, back to Resident Evil.
Sorry, I forgot that I wanted to kind of rant about this.
Because I, like I said, I am coming in as somebody.
I do know this.
Okay, hold on.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
I do know a little bit about the story of Resident Evil.
Like, for example, the person, the streamer that I was
watching I would rather have watched someone that was really
familiar with the series because the streamer I was watching
was not at all.
You did?
We're so proud of you.
Good brushing.
Thank you.
Because I want someone to be like, oh my gosh, the thing
that they just said was this thing from this game.
You know what I mean?
But they didn't.
But they didn't even recognize Wesker.
I reckon.
I was like, oh, shoot, that's Wesker.
Even I knew that guy.
But, um, yeah, the references.
So, probably, like, that's why I want to go back and play
the games and then play it myself, you know?
Um, but, anyway, um, what was I saying?
Oh, I liked the survival horror.
parts I liked Grace's parts but I also thought the storyline
for those parts were so stupid um wait it wasn't even Wesker
wait but it looked just like him it's Timu Wesker wait it
wasn't even him sorry I was like delusional while watching
this too I was in a feverish state
a lot of their actions make no sense yeah i thought okay
sorry i might be getting into spoiler territory but it's
complicated okay truly then clearly i need to play more of
the games to understand um like why did she take the girl
the blind girl from her cell and then drag her For a puzzle,
the Braille puzzle, that was literally solved through common
sense.
And then, yes, someone said it.
Like, literally, the puzzle was so easy.
Don't get me wrong, I didn't hate Grace.
I know a lot of people had mixed emotions about her.
I actually quite liked her.
hell she got a job at the fbi
oh damn it must be the like a nepo hire right like the like
the the secret organization is like yeah get that girl in we
need her later i don't i don't
i love grace but true it's it's pretty bad but don't Don't
get me wrong, I don't dislike her.
But then the fact that they...
Okay, spoilers, spoilers.
Boredom, sheer unadulterated boredom.
Then the fact that the girl gets killed because of Grace's
stupid-ass decisions made me...
Actually...
I was...
I was upset.
I was like, no.
And I know...
I saw the ending.
I know.
But.
I saw the ending.
I know.
But.
The helicopter scene was so.
I was like gripping my head being like.
What are we doing?
And then.
So I really liked the spooky bits.
The survival horror bits.
I thought that.
And it's funny because like you would switch to Leon.
his parts were just full action it was just like anybody
everybody that's just like yeah i love when leon kennedy
shoots and when he kicks and when he throws the axe like
that's that's their moment yeah his one-liners are amazing
but yeah re7 and re4 gameplay i thought they were great
because at first they were so short they were like they were
i thought they were good because it was just like oh yeah
he's punching and he's kicking and he's shooting and it
lasts like i don't know like 30 minutes and then he get back
into grace's part and it's spooky and you know i love me
like a good spooky game leon is drastically more funny than
i expected the guy is way too goofy
Um, but then when you get to Raccoon City, oh man, that's
what, I know that's like the MGS4 part, that's when everyone
is just like, this is my fan service, baby, I remember that
bridge, I remember, oh, that note from that little girl, I
remember that stuff, you know, but oh, it really started to
like, oh, it really started to drag a little bit, yeah,
that's their Shadow Moses, mm-hmm, mm-hmm, but Shadow Moses
didn't take that long, I'm just saying.
It just started to kind of drag a little bit, I think, with
his part.
Because, I just, it was seriously, it would be like, get to
one part, horde of zombies attacks you.
Run, run, run.
Get to another part, horde of zombies attack you.
Solve a puzzle, horde of zombies attack you.
Yeah, too many enemies, I thought.
Even when I'm watching, I'm just like, ugh.
The fan service goes and it's even dumber than you can
possibly imagine.
I also, I was like, what route is this man taking?
I know like the city is completely destroyed.
But like, surely you could just walk there.
I love that Not Wesker brought Grace to the police station
just to show her a traumatic video.
No other reason.
It's so funny.
it was the game was just so so freaking goofy
yeah they did not need to visit rpd i think leon just did
that because he felt like it i think he was just like oh old
time shake literally they're like you need to get to the
center of raccoon city and he's like la la la let me take
every detour in the world the route with a dirt bike rpg oh
yeah where what's his name uh victoria oh what was that
guy's name victor he was like pulling rpgs out of his hammer
space literally gideon victor give victor gideon yeah
victoria roman
unlimited rpg that guy was just like let me let me aim and
drive and shoot the rpg off my bike that part was awesome
that part was so awesome i have no complaints no notes keep
it going
Keep it going.
Okay, shall we play?
Berry, burry, burry?
Do you say burry or do you say burry?
So it's like berry, burry, burry.
Or do you say burry, burry, burry?
He didn't do a backflip.
They're out of 10.
No.
My accent, they're all the same.
Berry, burry, burry.
I guess it's the same as like, Do you say pecan or pecan?
Boorie.
Boorie?
Berry boorie?
Boo.
I saw your tweet about Needy Girl.
That I'm in it?
Yeah!
That I'm, that I'm, that I'm in the anime?
A little bit, tiny bit.
The teeniest bit.
Pecan.
Say it fast enough and you summon Barrybug.
Barry, Barry, Barry, Barry, Barry, Barry, Barry, Barry,
Barry, Barry.
I'm ESL.
Don't ask me.
ESL still counts.
You still have a way of saying things in English.
It's the English second language.
Not English, English no language.
Hmm.
I pronounce it Pete Rat Goomy Wait what is it Goomai Can die
Pete Rat Goomai Can die Funny the Rebecca photo Got saved
from the nuke
I don't know Too much of that city got saved I think Why
were there still zombies And why They were so dusty crusty,
but they're so tanky.
I don't know.
I feel like one shot and they should have just exploded into
dust.
Makes no sense to me.
They dug.
They're just little beetles.
G-Li, B-Li, P-T-Rat.
Ooh, I can't die.
That's right.
It wasn't a nuke, right?
It was retconned into not a nuke.
I remember people saying that.
That it was just like a regular Michelle.
It's been 20 years and they're not skeletons.
What are they feeding on?
They're feeding on the ranch.
Okay.
Play.
Oh my gosh, it's been over a month since I last played this
crazy.
Oh my God, we're doing well.
Bloody Ocean.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for that super chat.
Spy.
Oh yeah, the giant.
Giant spiders, right?
What?
Okay, is there a significance of that?
Like, is there like a previous Resident Evil game reference
to the giant spiders?
Animals mutate.
They were enemies in two.
Okay, okay.
Oh, huge spiders in RE1.
Okay, okay, okay.
playing RE1 and I was like in the very beginning and this
was when I was like you know a wee wisp and the camera
angles and then something jumped through the window and I
said I threw my hands up and I said I I need 10 more years
of experience before I experience this again I was like...
I will come back when I am a stronger ghost.
I was like literally the beginning of the game.
Now I'm ready, maybe.
Maybe I'm ready now.
I gotta remember how to play this game.
Oh yeah, baby.
I don't remember how to play this game.
Wait.
Oh!
How do I play?
How do I shoot?
Oh, here we go.
How do I get him to shh?
Wait, how do I suck?
Wait.
How do I suck?
I don't remember how to suck.
Oh, shoot.
Wait!
I don't remember, you guys!
Okay, I remember this.
I wonder if we can break down these walls.
Nope.
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Also this!
Can't...
Don't I need this for...
Up here?
Yes.
Okay.
Oh, oops.
It's key to suck, by the way.
And then there's a way to...
Oh, we have the blitz and everything.
We'll wait until tomorrow.
We gotta move our thing.
Hold on.
I have to remember how to direct my hole.
It's not yeah.
Uh, I need to eat all of this stuff back here.
I know, the BGM is so funky.
Oh, we wasted an entire day, but that's okay.
Don't worry about it, actually.
Eat to suck.
Oh yeah!
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Move the hole with Q!
Thank you!
I remember it being like...
um different controls all right what was i where are we
saving up for anything hmm fairy blitz oh we gotta upgrade
the sledgehammer so we can break the walls break these walls
we are the re spoilers done yes we're done with re nine
spoilers sorry automatically pops.
Okay, wait.
Auto star orb popper is kind of huge.
I'm not gonna lie.
Trampoline bounces thing towards the hole.
Wait, there's so much good stuff here.
Customize which berries grow from the plan.
I think the game is a little outside.
I think the star orb popper should be what we work towards.
Wait.
Lend up berries to make smoothies and break walls faster.
I gotta change the star key is five million dollars
trampoline can be useful I think though you want the star
okay let's see um fountain ready wait okay so come here come
here come here hole hole hole come here all right that
should be good enough right yeah yeah yeah yeah okay ready
uh wait no no a little back like here Okay, here, uh, there.
My hall?
There?
Like, I'm trying to center it.
Okay, here we go.
Uh, what do I do?
G!
H!
Oh, wait, I think I did it wrong.
Wait, I forgot.
I'm an idiot, sorry.
Uh, my bad.
I messed it up.
that's fine we got a pair oh we had a pair oh shoot let's
see if we can get our hole over here
yes yes yes and tomorrow we will upgrade we have we have 600
stars We need to upgrade our guys.
Maybe we don't have an apple.
Oh, look at that.
Look at that.
It ate so much.
Oh, I need more things.
Oh, that's fine.
We'll get a new one.
It's fine.
We got this.
Wait, special star.
Okay, well, actually, I don't remember.
what our special um oh there's also this password I don't
remember what the best uh what is the best our best berry is
right now like our highest berry do I sound congested you
guys I feel like I sound congestion censored sorry that's my
dojinchi collection
no no Okay, good.
A little.
Can you tell?
I don't want to get eaten.
I'm trying to get my money, please.
Please.
I'm getting what I deserve.
What I'm owed.
Did I get all of it?
It's so hard to tell.
Lamp.
I'm like a moth to a flame, baby.
I still sound better?
That's good.
Okay, unlock the auto star popper.
That will be huge when we do eat so much stuff, you know
what I mean?
So what we're going to do for this next one is we're going
to focus on upgrading.
uh, who is our best berry is the big question.
You upgraded to a pear.
So pear is our best.
Oh!
We got a peach.
Oh, we got peaches.
We got peaches.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches,
peaches, peaches.
Come here, come here.
Oh, I don't have enough for you.
That's okay.
Now you're a payer.
Wait, how much is it to be a coma?
Okay, I don't have enough.
Alright, that's fine.
Eat.
Consume.
We're gonna not worry about the stars right now.
I wonder if they'll autopop when I get the...
You know what I mean?
100 to be a pair.
Okay.
I wonder if they'll auto-pop when we get the auto-popper.
You know what I mean?
And then...
Oh, yeah, baby.
We'll just keep collecting money for now.
Give me cash.
I mean, hello.
reset overnight, though.
The stars?
No, they don't.
If I don't pop these, I still get to keep them.
Alright, we want to get more peaches.
We want to get more peaches and such.
We probably...
It's okay.
I won't focus on moving it right now.
Obviously, we're almost out of time anyway, so...
Ah, damn, it was too late.
So close.
I probably could have moved it over there to create more
stars, but it's okay.
Did we get enough for...
No, I don't think we got enough for the autopopper.
Dang.
So close.
We're so close.
Every little coin counts.
Ah!
Okay.
Tomorrow.
So does the hole being bigger mean more money coming out of
it?
No, but it means...
So basically when you eat things...
So you put berries in to get cash.
Then you move the hole to eat things.
When it eats things, it produces stars.
And the stars are what you use to upgrade your berries.
Tomorrow.
Tomorrow!
It's the kind of game you play in a dream.
It feels like it, though.
Look at all of them.
Look at you.
Zeno?
Grow.
Yeah, nice.
Oh, I hit you in the head, you idiot.
You're kind of stupid, aren't you?
That's okay.
Who are you?
Elbow!
I think I like Elbow so much because it sounds like Elmo.
And Elmo was my Sesame Street Oshie.
I had an Elmo plushie that I picked all the fur off of.
He was bald.
he looked a little demonic but I liked him that way people
be like what's wrong with your Elmo there's nothing wrong
with him he was fine just the way that he was
what is this golden golden golden
nice whoa what was that did it do that before oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh more stuff nice wait do I have a golden
strawberry up here?
I don't know what this does, but...
Elmo karaoke was perfect.
I'm glad you thought so.
Thank you.
Yeah, Elmo is my Yoshi.
Still don't know what he has about against that rock,
though.
He really hated the rock.
Not like Dwayne the Rock Johnson.
But like...
There was like a little rock going on.
I hate it.
Okay.
Hopefully we can get these in.
Hopefully, hopefully, hopefully.
Okay.
Oh.
Not a ton, but...
Oh my god.
I'm gonna fall in.
Oh, I didn't fall in.
Oh, I made it.
I lived.
I lived until the tail.
Yeah, Rocky.
He hates that guy.
Have you guys ever seen those clips?
Of like...
People will be like, tell Rocky happy birthday and he's like
it's just a rock he's like what am I telling Rocky happy
birthday for he's a rock Elmo trying to speak common sense
into everybody my my puppet can't have this much common
sense Elmo's jealous Elmo has nothing to be jealous of
Elmo's precious oh I just noticed the bed has eyeballs and
they follow me yuck all right auto popper here we go
okay when does it happen oh oh my god happy fourth of july
I was scared for a second.
I was like, no way.
It didn't work.
You guys, it's over.
I have to pop all of these by hand.
But we don't.
Yahoo!
Hello.
All right.
Let's get some more stuff over here.
Come on, hold.
175 stars.
That means we can upgrade.
Oh, thank you for that.
I didn't see how much it was to
I didn't see how much it was to upgrade we're gonna get the
tent here it comes yeah consume consume
upgrade the peaches let's see how much it is you are Not
enough.
Obviously, I didn't think I had enough.
Oopsie!
Wait, I thought...
Oh, it's 200, isn't it?
Oops, my bad.
Consume.
And then tomorrow, we'll get the other side.
Ooh, a golden raspberry.
No, no, no!
Get the little shed!
Get it!
Oh, man.
I was worried that would happen.
We were so close.
They're like struggling over there, all those coins.
We gotta bring the hole over here a little bit.
I'm glad they don't fall into the hole.
But I almost wish they did fall into the hole, so I
auto-collected a little bit, you know.
Mm-hmm.
The Shed survived for now.
So stinking close, though.
Hello!
We got a little more money than we usually do, which is
nice, I suppose.
Look at it, like, stuck in the ground.
Oh, wait, I need to go around.
Is there any in here?
to figure out this password.
And we can rewind.
I don't think I want to do that yet.
My nephew has a little Elmo plushie that holds an ice cream
cone.
I taught my nephew that the Elmo eats both ice cream and
people.
And says, yay, ice cream!
That's terrible things to happen around.
What do you...
Why?
Wait.
You saw the password?
No, I think what you...
Here, I'll show you.
I'll show you what you saw.
on the wall right you have such a good you have such a good
eye but this is to the radio i got it previously but thank
you so much for for being on the lookout if that's what
you're referring to all right let's go this way this way
this way
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, give me more pages over and
there.
Why don't, I feel like I could be optimizing this better,
and I'm not quite sure how.
You know what I mean?
Like, I feel, maybe I need more berry buddies.
I mean, we need to hire, we need to spend our money on that,
I think.
We'll get some more berries.
Because right now, I think that's our biggest hiccup, is we
just don't have enough berries to collect.
you know makes sense yeah that's what I think is our issue
at the moment whoa
can we can we get this tent nice nice oh wait wait wait here
here here uh I get more berries it would also be nice to
extend our day a little bit so that we can do more stuff too
eat more things Berry
crunch.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yes!
Get the tree!
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, oh, huge!
Oh, huge!
Oh, good.
We got a lot of stuff.
We consumed.
We ate and ate and ate.
Huge outcome.
Wish the money glowed more.
That's a pair.
Huge gains.
We're going to get the slide tomorrow, everybody trust.
Actually, I feel like our hole is not big enough to get the
slide.
Is it just me?
Maybe it...
My, what is it?
My eyes are too big for my...
My hole is too big for my stomach?
Wait, uh, my eye...
What is that?
My eyes are larger than my stomach?
Is that the saying?
What's the saying?
Trust?
Whole movement range!
Wait, we should get the hide!
So we can eat more.
I got it, right?
Something like that.
Sorry, I dropped my fork.
My saying is better.
My eyes are larger than my holes.
Eyes are too big for my stomach.
I do that often though.
I'm like the type of hungry ghost where I eat very small and
then I'm hungry in like two hours, you know what I mean?
So it's like, I'm like, it's...
Some people are just like, oh that's like healthier.
But at the same time, it's so inconvenient.
Because I want to go to a buffet and I want to pig out, you
know what I mean?
Oh, a berry buddy is $100,000.
Maybe I should do the whole movement range then.
That's pretty substantial.
150 to 250.
It is healthier, but it's super inconvenient.
Yeah, it's so annoying because also I go to a restaurant and
sometimes portions are so large and I can't finish it.
And it'll be something that doesn't, like, that doesn't go
home well.
You know what I mean?
It's so annoying.
Because I'm like, this is delicious and I want to finish it.
And also, I can't take it home because it won't reheat well.
And I'm like, no.
Please, make, give me like a half size.
There are some ramen places.
In my brain, I was thinking of ramen.
Because that's what happens with, that's like usually the
food that happens.
And there are some places that give you half portion size
ramen bowls.
Which is so nice.
It's cool as it goes so you can just make your tummy grow!
Raising is actually pretty healthy though.
Ramen servings are pretty big.
I know, why do they do that?
Oh man, now I'm hungry.
Sorry!
I didn't mean to make you hungry.
What do you guys think we should get?
Should we save up for another berry buddy?
Or should we extend our whole movement range?
I think 150 to 250 is pretty significant.
I'm not gonna lie.
The whole sounds better.
It is almost double, right?
Okay, let's go for the whole movement right now.
Upgrade flower to bush.
Upgrade plants to a bush and bush grows.
Three berries.
Okay, we need more berries because we need more cash money,
baby.
To get to that 5 million, we're like...
And then also, we need to...
We need the sledgehammer.
maybe the trampoline would be good too i don't know there's
so many things i think we need bigger gains before we can
work towards unlocking these so the whole movement range
will allow us more stars which will allow us to upgrade our
berries so next we will try to get another berry buddy we're
running out of stuff to eat though that's the thing so we're
gonna run out of
It's tough decisions out here.
I think we can...
Well,
we'll be able to do a blitz next time too, which will be
nice.
Yep.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Yes, yes, eat, eat, eat.
Consume, consume, consume, consume.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Ooh, we got some jazz today.
I'm a fan of the soundtrack.
But none of those are decisions bad.
Oh, it ate it.
It ate it.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe.
I can't believe it ate it.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Let's upgrade.
You?
Can I?
No.
How much is it?
400.
Upsie.
Downsy.
You are now a payer.
I mean, sorry, a peach.
You've always been a peach though.
To me.
Oh.
Alright.
Consume, consume, consume, consume.
Money,
money, money, money.
We need our mo- oh, don't fall in.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches,
peaches, peaches, peaches.
I think the trailer will give us a good amount though.
all of that only gave us a couple one star?
Oh, just kidding a couple stars?
Oh, just kidding there's many more stars?
We can get that nice alright, oh alright, tomorrow the
trailer
I love you Wyatt, did you guys hear Donald Glover as Yoshi?
Why is he so good at it?
Yoshi!
Why is he so good at Yoshi noises?
It's really funny when people are like Donald Glover as
Yoshi?
I just can't see it.
But anyone who watched Community gets it.
They're like, I only see him as Childish Gambino.
I can't see him as that guy.
I know, that's like him.
But I only see him as Uh, as...
What was it?
Yeah, Troy!
Troy and Abbot in the morning!
I only see him as that.
Because I found him first through community, so, you know.
Does the hole come into the house?
Oh!
I entered the building and disabled the security system.
We've had recent issues with our passwords being...
shared and figured it would be a plausible explanation for a
break-in.
We almost got eaten.
Wait, maybe she'll tell us the password.
So, so far, a recap of the lore, from what I remember.
Yeah, this game does have a bit of a story.
That girl, I believe she was the host of a kid's TV show
called Berry Berry, Berry.
And I can't remember.
anything else sorry I'm the worst oh there's another one oh
wait entered the building and disabled the security system
we've had recent issues oh wait I'm trapped oh oh oh it
would be a plausible explanation for a break that was close
that was so close oh my gosh okay so the ones that I did
collect are on the shelf gotta
all right clutch I'm a gamer
Beep, beep,
beep.
Huge.
Did you hear Glenn Powell from Top Gun?
I did!
Glenn Powell from Top Gun!
I did, I did!
Alright, we're gonna do the Blitz.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Alright, we're about to do the Blitz, baby.
Wait, oh, like, here.
No, no, like here.
That should be good.
Okay, but, ah, a little closer.
Like, ugh.
I can't position it.
Come on.
I'm trying to...
No!
Why are you moving it so far away?
I'm trying!
Oh, whatever.
It doesn't matter.
Blitz go!
Is that an apple?
And...
Fountain!
Let's see if I...
The hole grows larger!
Wait.
Is this... No?
Oh, uh...
That's a pumpkin.
Oh, I don't know.
You?
I need a golden banana!
Oh, shoot.
Uh...
Alright, let's move our hole.
Yippee!
Come here, come here.
Hole?
Consume this...
Right now.
Wait, do I need to consume this?
Has it just been, like, sitting here waiting to be eaten?
Uh-oh, it's already time's up.
Oh my gosh.
We got this Yes!
We got this one too.
Come on.
We almost had it
Yeah, if you want to for some reason I thought it was just a
special decoration couldn't be eaten But I think I just
missed it like a dummy done Did you get the golden blueberry
and lower tier fruits?
Oh, I think that's that's why I want to do.
Wait, look how much money we got though we can get another
another berry another berry pal that's why i wanted one
though so we can kind of start on the lower tier and like
collect those lower golden fruits we don't have to upgrade
him immediately you know
oh it's so dark scary
this game is unnerving but at least it's not scary scary I
can't see the hole though.
What was it?
I think I got everything.
Spooky.
Okay.
Berry Buddy!
Incoming!
Wait.
Let's see what else we can get.
Berry Blitz growth.
Bonus growth.
Money.
And also Okay, what I'm gonna do is get the berry buddy And
then next thing we'll do is
Do I want the bush instead of the flower Or the butt buddy I
wonder if you can reduce the blitz countdown We can Oh wait,
yeah Oh, no, I guess the duration It seems We're close to
getting the sledgehammer too Which we need Oh, there's too
many things!
There's too many things I feel like we need!
Three berries is like three buddies.
That's what I was thinking too.
You're right.
To a tree!
What?
1.5 million bucks!
Crazy.
We'll do the cooldown.
It's cheap enough.
We make that pretty easily.
Having the cooldown is good, I think.
Yeah.
Increased day length would be good too.
Alright.
We're gonna focus.
We're gonna aim for.
Increased day length.
New berry buddy.
Sledgehammer.
Those are our three things that we're aiming for.
Sweet dreams.
Wow!
Look at the cute.
Because this is like the last thing we have to eat.
Besides, uh...
This.
Oh, we have some trees over here too.
We do have some trees.
Come here!
Thank you!
Having our gun is kind of useless now, huh?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Hannah Montana, Disney...
Transition.
Yeah!
Whoa!
Sorry, that scared me.
I didn't realize it was there.
Whoa, look how many berries are dropping.
Wait, kind of crazy.
We're going sicko mode.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Why are all my berries lying on the job?
Come on, guys.
We've only made...
We've only made barely any money.
Insano mode.
Insano style.
have a lot more um i can upgrade wait uh one of our peaches
you who are you zina welcome to banana wait can i get it can
i get it please please please please please please please
please please please i think we got it no
so mean it's okay it's close by we'll be able to get it
easily
We'll be able to get it easily.
We need to make big bucks, you guys.
We're making petty change right now.
I'm gonna go under.
My business.
My business is not gonna last.
So, there's so many tapes.
Where else can I find them?
You know?
Maybe outside.
side of the I can't stop thinking about growing the whole
honestly
okay we'll increase the day length like I said I would yeah
27k a day isn't enough if I I gotta be a bajillionaire
the painting seem interesting yeah there's like hidden lore
and I want to know more I'm just not done cracking up at my
woollolo clip I like the berry chooser too but we need we
need much more money to our vacuum capacity could also go
change all it's been a rough week happy to see Aminto stream
there it is wait it's only Sunday I hope you're okay.
I hope so.
Just woolo-lo on the haters.
Woolo-lo.
Woolo-lo!
Alright, let's go eat.
Maybe there are like some tape...
Oh, there's a security camera and everything.
There, there, there, there.
What are you doing in here?
What are you doing in my office?
Here he goes!
It's nice!
Over here.
Get the trees.
Oh my gosh, we have no stars.
We got no money.
We need the sledgehammer really bad, huh?
We need to bust out of this place.
I keep getting golden apples.
I think those tree wrinkles healing.
Then why am I not healed?
I'm just kidding.
Golden banana.
Wait, did I get the tree?
I think so.
You need to watch myself.
I'm too embarrassed.
Even watching clips of myself sometimes, I'm like, why did I
say that?
Why did I say that for?
A Minto stream a day keeps the doctors away.
Or maybe...
It makes it worse.
Oh, nice.
Wait, wait, there's a little pot there.
There we go.
Now we have everything.
We have literally everything on this map.
Oh, geez.
I'm not optimized at all.
I'm failing as a barrier.
Thank you, Clippers.
Yeah, thank you, Clippers.
Sharing in my most embarrassing and intimate moments.
Was that guy always there?
The guy up there?
Yeah, he's been there.
We'll just collect the cash for now.
Okay!
After getting the bananas!
Look, we never made $30,000 before!
The bananas, like, kind of grew our...
Money count.
Pretty good, actually.
Look at that.
Nice, not half bad.
Alright.
Watch your awesome moments.
My epic moments.
My epic gamer moments.
When I do gaming things.
And I'm really cool and awesome.
Okay, but this is fine.
Because now I can just kind of place the hole here.
And like suck.
And.
Shouldn't be so bad.
Alright.
We'll wait for the sledgehammer.
Gamer.
You aren't healing because you're healing us!
We'll heal you with the happy steroid beam!
Oh my gosh, the meds, the meds, the meds!
I have to take more meds after this.
The moments when you say hot dog are the best.
What can I say?
Every time is a hot dog moment.
Every moment with you is a hot dog moment.
Oh, I was early.
Like there?
All right.
Let's get second!
Whoa!
All right, give me big gains, big cash, everybody.
We need money, money, money, money, money, money, money,
money, money, money, money, money.
Banana's important.
Important to the economy.
The berry economy.
Okay, Mr. Crabbs.
I like money.
I don't need you over here, man.
Come on.
You're making this real difficult on me.
That guy has, like, made and ruined his career.
You know, because, like, he was in that Detroit Become Human
game.
And all you can hear is Mr. Crabs.
All you can hear is Mr. Crabs speaking.
His voice is way too iconic.
he's in deadlock i don't know what that game is i've only
heard of it
get up please we are not sleeping on the job now aren't we
there's a villain in highlander yeah but he just he's
awesome mr crabs
he's what wait oh i think okay i thought the pipe like
changed Are you stuck here?
If so, awesome.
Don't move.
No, we need more money.
Oh, golden, golden.
Ah, dang.
That's okay.
That's alright.
We made $50,000 today.
At least.
Very good job.
Everybody pulling their weights, especially you banana.
Yeah, 50k ain't half bad.
But it ain't great if we're trying to get to 1 million.
We need like 100k plus.
Okay, how do I get to my bed, huh?
Come on, Mr. Hole.
Come over here.
It's a lot of bananas.
We only have 105 stars.
We can't upgrade anyone else.
That potassium.
It's liquid gold, baby.
We can get another berry, buddy.
We do need...
We need a golden...
Oh, sorry.
Golden...
Oh my gosh.
Really?
I can't believe talking?
Makes my cough so much worse.
Um, we need a golden blueberry and we need a golden
strawberry.
Okay.
I almost want to rewind.
Actually, we're pretty close to the sledgehammer.
Let's hold off.
And we'll get the sledgehammer.
We should be able to get it next time.
So, I think the sledgehammer will be much more useful since
we need, you know, we need the stars desperate.
squatching them grow like this.
It feels a little good though.
I'm not gonna lie.
Something about it.
It ain't right.
That hole ain't right.
I'll tell you what.
Yeah, we need more Star Stead.
Don't fall in.
Okay.
Ignore me, I guess.
The longer days have been nice too.
We got like the extra seconds and all they've been real nice
silly banana I haven't optimized this at all though I'm a
failure at a berry barrier no stop please don't run away
from me where are my bananas there they are Oh my goodness.
So many of them.
All around here.
Come here.
Oh yeah baby.
I'd say this is as optimal as it can be right now.
You think so?
I don't know.
I feel like I should have made better upgrade decisions.
But it's fine.
We are making big cash stacks.
Maybe.
Probably.
A little bit.
Thank you.
Okay, great stuff, Minto.
Thank you!
Bananas are important to get in.
Please, please drop it.
It's like talking to a dog.
Drop it.
Drop the banana.
and then they have that really guilty look on their face
they're like
dogs are like so unintentionally funny i don't think i do i
i'm glad that animals don't realize how funny they are
because they're just so funny they're so naturally hilarious
all right sledgehammer yeah what is this auto coin pickup
range you know what we'll do that too Why not?
It was cheap.
Do we make that?
Cats are natural comedians.
I know.
Alright, today we'll be all about destroying.
Destruction.
Oh, where'd it go?
Oh, there.
Sorry, everybody.
Where are we now?
We're under construction.
Oh, it's smoothies!
I know.
Sometimes, like, I look at my cat and, like, you're just
so...
You're too goofy.
How do you exist, you silly creature?
Ah, yes.
And they're so cute!
Oh, to be reincarnated as a cat.
Please, please, please.
I don't want to just be minkid-y.
I'm out of my furry era.
Actually, if I wish to be a cat, does that make me more of a
furry than anything?
Yes?
Shoot.
Well, shoot.
Well, better to start meow than later.
Destruction, destruction, destruction, destruction,
destruction, destruction.
Boo!
I know you'll have it.
Thank you.
Oh.
I'm not hit with enough force.
It did say with the chain.
I could destroy the walls faster, but I mean, this doesn't
take too long.
I just gotta spend a whole day doing it.
Oh, these gnomes are trying to move out.
Like, they're like, parked.
They're getting their cars ready.
I don't think the hole can absorb the walls.
I think that's why you have to get, yeah.
Wait.
What?
Where did...
Wait, I got a star, but I don't know from what?
I didn't eat anything.
I was kind of weird.
I like how smoothies is really...
Oh, because it's one of these!
Oh, it's a special star.
Stars auto-generate sometimes.
Oh, do they?
Oh, I guess.
Oh, that's nice.
I guess if you're, like, really stuck, you can't get
soft-locked.
That's pretty nice.
I think we made 36,000.
Okay.
Not bad.
You can make smoothies.
That is true.
I gotta get the chainsaw for that.
Actually, I forgot to see how much it costs.
Can I open these?
The drawers?
No.
Alright, hole!
Let's stick our hole on them.
Get them, girl!
actually probably it would have been better to get all those
cones but whatever
delicious banana wait strawberry was that one that we needed
wait i think so
i think we needed the strawberry maybe
oh no we had the strawberry which one's this What is that?
Because that's peach.
What are you?
I don't remember.
Watermelon?
I don't think we had watermelon.
Oh my god, this house.
What's that?
Mellon?
Can I get the house?
Oh, our hole's not big enough yet.
It's okay.
Don't feel bad.
Plum probably.
We get so many golden apples.
I don't know why.
Oh my gosh, so many.
Oh.
Nice.
Brunson!
Thank you so much, Brunson!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
What the heck?
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Holy cow.
No, no, we have so many bananas, please!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run.
We need the money, we need the money, we need the money.
Ow.
That was a loss for us today, everybody.
That was a loss for us.
It's okay.
Did you hear that?
Members are free?
My face, when memberships are free?
Oh my gosh, Britson!
Thank you for another 50!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much.
Oh my goodness.
I can't see if I can get in there.
I need the hole to move a bit more.
Over this way.
So I can go get the money in the corner.
I thought it was like $1,000, but that's okay.
We made a lot of stars.
Which are also important.
Um...
Free memberships, wow!
It's true, I definitely didn't pay for this.
Thank you.
You did.
You did pay for it.
Oh, the chainsaw.
Let's see how much it is.
Trampoline.
Chainsaw.
75,000!
We can do that.
Easy.
What are the smoothies though?
Wake up.
Thank you!
Hello!
Are we okay?
What's happening?
Thank you!
This is broken, I don't know!
What's happening?
Why so many?
It's not my birthday.
Or anything.
Okay.
Is this a form of tax evasion?
I texted my tax lady this morning.
I told people about my taxes.
I was like, I'm scared of taxes because I always owe so
much.
They were like, how much do you owe?
And I was like, this amount.
And they were like, they were like, what the hell?
We think you're getting robbed or something.
So, um, I'm gonna try and do my taxes different.
Oh, the fountain!
You're right, you're right.
Okay, uh, blitz!
Go!
Yeah!
Oh my god, look at all the bananas!
Holy cow!
And fountain!
Oh!
Yeah, it says I'm doing great.
The hole grows larger.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, it's still spewing money.
Let's go!
Yes, yes.
Nice.
Alright, we will be able to get the chainsaw.
Chainsaw, man.
Wow, what are you doing all the way over here?
Oh my god, wait, did you get the more brown saw?
Thank you!
Please.
Your wallet?
Hello?
Hello, please?
I'm concerned?
I'm concerned!
Thank you!
Very much!
Lucky, lucky.
Where's the hole?
Oh, we're there.
Alright!
Alright, alright!
Chainsaw.
We could get another thing though.
There's another sledgehammer upgrade!
Very, very interesting.
So we have another wall to knock down.
Guaranteed more than 10% of chat is now remembered.
Crazy!
Crazy work.
For the tax evasion fund.
Yeah, the chainsaw can also break walls.
But I wonder if we need the sledgehammer.
hammer to do the special walls you know what i mean or like
to get like obviously like if if we have to upgrade the
sledgehammer to then have the chainsaw unlock as well
upgrade the blitz we can't upgrade the we can upgrade the
bonus growth that is true we do get a lot of money from it
we'll do I think that's good.
All right, how do I use the sledgehammer?
Whoa!
Blend up berries to create smoothies!
Feed smoothies to the whole to per- Oh, temporarily multiply
berry growth rate.
Eat?
How do I use you?
Whoa!
Oh.
Am I doing it right?
Am I doing this right?
Barry Massacre?
It's filling up.
Oh, this is huge.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's so much easier.
That's funny.
Wait, this is huge.
oh i got the smoothie okay and so then i oh probably what we
want to do is like make the smoothie do the blitz right and
everything and then like we would make crazy money it stacks
Wait, the golden banana!
As much as I would have put it in there.
Oh, wait.
Where's my chainsaw?
I forgot about it already.
Wait, let's just get the bananas in.
Bananas are high money.
Bananas are big money.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Ah, dang.
It's still with the money.
Okay, so maybe smoothies are the way to go.
Are we at risk of mintification?
from watching you.
But, I mean, if I possess you so many times, you might kind
of start picking up my hat, which is something.
But does that be so cute?
You start being like, good morning, Minto.
All on your own.
Thank you, thanks for the get-in.
Rusty glitch phase.
Thank you for the fun, get-in.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
All right, tomorrow, Jane's on man.
Juiced two times.
Oh, it's still lasting.
Whoa, I see, I see.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Beep, beep, beep.
trying to decide what would be good to focus on probably
like a trampoline 250,000 we could do that trampoline would
be good probably I wonder how it works bounces things
towards the hole is it like auto
can you upgrade your battery buddy There's also the juiced
growth multiplier.
I can do it.
Did I see a doctor?
Only if it lasts like more than five hours.
It auto-targets the hole.
Okay, nice.
That's a bomb already, Miko.
Thank you so much for 23, but it's almost two- Why so many
people are almost at two years.
That's crazy!
Two years!
No way!
I haven't been streaming though.
I'm worried.
So many new two-year buddies said, Yeah!
You got it a little early, didn't you, fake me?
The people that are like the true OGs got it a little bit
early.
That's crazy!
Time moves fast.
One more month.
Thank you guys!
Almost two years!
No!
Well, baby, I barely got to 15 months.
That's a long time.
What are you talking about?
That's over a year.
OG, OGs.
Thank you, guys.
Holy cow.
There's so many of you.
Ah!
I was late to the party.
Never late.
Oh, 23, 23, 23.
17, 19.
17.
23, 1!
Thank you!
Sorry, Minto, I'm new.
Why would you apologize?
I love when new people find me, too.
What?
That's, like, the best thing, actually.
I'm doing something right.
New people are finding me and watching me.
And then people are sticking around enough to watch me for
23 months.
Maybe I'm doing something right.
Don't get emotional with me, don't because if you cry, I
cry.
Sorry, I'm trying to keep it in.
I'm not going to lie.
I already used mine.
But 23 months.
See you soon.
Thank you so much for the fight, Gipton.
Not in the 20s yet, but legal, baby.
It's like she knows what she's doing.
I don't.
Syntax welcome back.
Thank you so much for the Gipton.
Zatman Phantom from Densetsu.exe?
Oh my gosh!
I was watching the Kiyara and Ina concert and it was just so
good.
Both of them were so good.
And it made me so excited for the Densetsu 3D concert.
I was like, oh my gosh.
Like, you know, in just a couple months, you know, I'll be
able to dance on a stage, you know, too.
And with my friends.
And, you know, it was so inspiring to watch the two of them.
Like, they deserved a concert like this so much sooner than
when they got it.
But I'm just so happy it happened.
Like, I'm just so happy for them.
It's so awesome.
Hollow myth or legends They are truly myths right I hope
that you know Me and other Densets and members were working
Really really hard So that we can put on even half of as
good of a show As they did So But I was just so inspired I
was like oh my gosh they are So awesome I joined because of
your astrobot snake Freak out I knew right then and there to
join.
Thank you.
Was it because of how I reacted?
Or is it because you're like a Metal Gear head too?
I'm so curious who your guest is going to be.
I saw it.
Shall I even say?
I honestly don't know when it's going to be announced.
I was hoping sooner.
Both, both, both.
I like Metal Gear just a little bit.
It's Ariana Grande.
I'm nervous that...
You know, obviously to me, the guest is so amazing.
And I'm just worried that, like, because it's taking so
long, people are thinking it's, like, way grander than it
is.
Hi, Vito.
First time watching.
Hi, Syntax Era.
I've never seen you before.
Thank you so much for the super chat.
It's the first time ever, thank you!
One guest was announced already, two guests were announced!
For the Densetsu, first...
Sorry, first 3D live, we have...
Iron Mouse, and then we have, um...
Demon Dice?
I think it's really funny that people were like trying to
guess based on the color.
But I don't think people realize that...
Iron Mouse was pink and Phoebe is pink.
That's just a coincidence.
My guests, the guests were not color-coded.
That's me.
I'm green.
That's just because...
It's just a...
Yeah, it's just a coinkie thing.
She's green.
I'm green.
What if you've noticed?
Well...
Hmm.
Maybe I shouldn't say that.
We do have a little bit of surprises still.
I mean, obviously my guest to be announced and then some
other things.
We have like a theming going on for our guests in a way.
So no hints, no help.
No, no, I'm not going to say anything.
What if it's Shrek?
Shrock.
I hope it's Jack Black.
I wonder if he would probably, I feel like Jack Black would
be down for a, for a strange sort of thing, like a VTuber
concert.
It's Apollo.
Have you guys seen that one band that has the, the, you're
guessing Donna Burke?
I will not confirm nor deny.
But there's like a band that has a bird that like does
Screamo.
wouldn't it be so funny if that was my guest like they just
wheel out a bird yeah i think i think the band is called
hate beak
oh my my cough is getting a bit worse but we're pushing
we're pushing i'm having too much fun with the game honestly
i want to beat it today i don't know how much i have left
but We'll see.
Okay, bring my hole here.
Right?
What?
What's my...
Oh, I think we're aiming for the trampoline.
We have 300 stars.
Oh, yeah.
My...
This.
Yeah, yeah.
More, more.
More smoothie.
No, come on.
Why am I so bad at this?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, thank you, chainsaw man.
Chainsaw, man.
Yeah, because you're a man and you have a chainsaw.
Oh.
Wait.
Am I good now to...
Golden banana?
Huge.
We probably could stop.
getting more i want to focus on cash money though maybe
we'll get the trampoline and then we'll start eating things
right themes
and such it
was the ending of all time i mean it's so this is gonna
sound very strange but it's so japanese if you consume
enough japanese media especially like especially like
regular movies and stuff you'll find that so many of them
have like very just quote unquote unsatisfying endings which
you know obviously it's unsatisfying so you're like dang i
don't know if i like this yeah ambiguous open ended yeah
exactly so it just becomes it's you know it's frustrating
but holistic in a sense, you know, where you're just like
all, oh, oops, I forgot to, you know, it doesn't, not
everything can be, obviously, I don't know anything about
Chainsaw on my own.
I was, I was partially explained the ending, so I know like
a tiny bit about it, but, um, yeah.
I can appreciate it, but sometimes I just want closure in a
story.
No, I get that 100%.
it's it's to me i'm like it's a double-edged sword in a
sense where it's just like sometimes it i don't know like i
said i don't know enough about chainsaw man to say if it's
fitting to how the story was but sometimes it just doesn't
feel good you know what i mean as an anime only i would be
worried about being spoiled but i wonder if they'll even
bother animating i think they will no i don't think it was
that i mean i think it's divisive but i don't think it's
like controversial to animate it
it's very fitting to fujimoto that guy is insane oh yeah
it's better it's about on par for how fujimoto writes what
else has he done i wonder how one piece will finally end i
am waiting for dang it detective conan my conclusion i need
that series to end like 10 years ago oh fire punch oh wow i
haven't seen fire punch either conan
will never end at prince money chinese girlies love conan
it's kind of insane it's kind of insane
Kudo, please give Hayabara a chance.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, wait a second.
That's not my ship.
It will only end if the author is still alive.
I don't know.
What was I going to say?
I feel like recently a lot of Shonen have been ending.
And people are just really mixed on the endings.
Like, one...
My Hero Academia, a lot of people were kind of like, really?
Maybe it's just the loud people, you know?
There's always going to be the loudest people that you see
their opinions.
But I just don't know what people expect.
Endings are difficult, aren't they?
Yeah.
I think it's just the loud crowd.
Okay, but the Oshinoko ending...
I don't, exactly, like I'm always just like, I don't know
what I want from the ending, but sometimes I'm like, see the
ending and I'm like, oh.
Kind of hope for your end never ends.
I need to watch the second season.
I need to get caught up.
Maybe I'll watch it on my vacation.
No one likes the Oshinoko ending.
Endings are difficult.
You mess it up and it validates all of your progress.
like it's kind of crazy how the ending will make like it
gets game game of thrones you know where people are just
like just don't even bother the ending is so bad or stop
after this season you know but i don't know what it is about
shonen and people not enjoying the endings of the of the
show or the series it's kind of crazy what's a good do you
have an opinion of what's a good
an overall by the general audience accepted shonen ending
you know I just I'm trying to think I think attack on titan
FMA oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
so true that's so true oh Dragon Ball GT is ending oh I
don't I don't know if I've heard about that one.
Digimon Adventure, I said that counts.
Zero no skaiima!
I think that's...
more...
Sainan, right?
Toradora.
I love, I love.
Wait, Attack on Titans ending was hated.
Okay, I couldn't remember.
Everyone is so divisive all the time.
Ah!
Everyone is always so divisive.
Hmm.
It's Black Lagoon Shonen?
I think...
Well, it's like...
It's like...
Hard to say because like...
Shonen is kind of...
Categorized in the manga published...
In like the manga magazine it's published.
Yeah, it's more say than...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, but it has...
I feel like it has like a Shonen feel, but I guess not,
actually.
It's just kind of mature.
Hmm.
Yeah, so say Nen, I guess, yeah.
So not Shonen.
Black Lagoon is with the guns, right?
I'm trying to think.
I feel like probably for Shonen...
I have no idea.
I'm trying to think.
I guess Full Metal Alchemist is really the only thing that
comes to mind with an ending people liked.
Hmm.
I was about to say only sports shonen have decent endings
and it's because it's always like yeah I overcame the thing
we're all buddies everything's good
it's because I don't know the sports shonen is always so
like oh it always there's just something about sports shonen
that makes you feel so like yeah yeah The coming of age,
yeah!
It's kind of crazy that I had this conversation in two chats
already.
In my opinion, Zajbel and Gintama had good endings.
Jojo had pretty good endings, but it became a seignan from
Part 7 onwards.
I thought Gintama was still going.
At least the anime.
Did the manga end?
It's annoying the fact that people only like endings if they
lived happily ever after is irritating.
expected no i agree that's why i actually really like
bittersweet endings it makes me feel like i'm feeling
something you know corey in the house at the best anime
ending ever everybody can agree oh the manga and anime are
both over oh i'm so behind i was never super into gintama
anyway i was like a casual fan because it was funny
I like a good tragedy I eat that up I eat up a good tragedy
baby
but you know it's good to have variety it's good to have
happy endings it's good to have better sweet endings and
tragedy endings and you know not everything can end the same
all right let's see what we want to buy oh we were aiming
for oh we're so close to the trampoline okay we'll just save
up for that or never endings like Conan no no please let it
end please let it go Let it go!
Let him go!
There's so much happening in Conan now.
Actually, there's like so much happening and it's all the
same stuff that like kind of is like...
How do I say like, oh...
The organization is still doing their thing!
I don't know if you guys know anything about Conan.
I know unfortunately way too much about Detective Conan.
went to usj um and they had a conan like attraction it
wasn't really a ride it was like a theater show which was
really cool actually like they had live action and then also
um like the 2d characters on the screen so it was really
neat and
um But some of my friends didn't know anything about Conan,
so I was just like, okay, and then...
And then, Hibara, she took this, and she's actually...
She's Sherry, and she's...
My Conan lore.
Oh, I do need to put a smoothie!
Wait, wait, wait!
Don't eat the smoothie!
I actually don't know if it can eat the smoothie.
Wait, can I eat the slide?
Oh, it's fine.
Wait, I do need a smoothie.
Get my chainsaw.
I got my chainsaw!
Smoothie, smoothie, smoothie!
Give me a- There we go.
Alright, run, run, run, run.
Hibara is one of my favorite characters ever.
She's so good.
Wait, no, no, no, please, please, please, please.
Ah!
Oops.
How am I supposed to put it in there?
But there are, if you're interested in Detective Conan, I'd
say it's a pretty good series.
But find one of those guides that gets rid of the filler if
you're truly only interested in the story.
Some of the filler, though, I'll say is really funny.
Because they're, like, so off the wall, like, what the hell
is this case?
Like, you could tell that they just didn't know what to ride
this week.
There's a specific recipe you have to follow.
Interesting.
Oh, I heard something.
It was like a...
Oh,
my...
Fly doesn't work right now.
Oh!
Bank of Thou!
Sorry, a million total!
Yippee!
Okay, we got the trampoline.
The dark is so scary.
I was afraid at first, but now I'm not because...
Wait, does it say what smoothie recipe we have to follow?
I didn't know there were different recipes.
Maybe I'm going to look around for some secrets.
Look around for any tapes and such.
I wonder if I've been eating tapes and I don't even notice.
Lore?
Let us know if you want a hint.
Yeah, actually, I would love one.
My head is pretty foggy because of the medicine.
So, because I'm getting over sickness.
So honestly, any help right now would be really appreciated.
Recipe is on the computer.
Oh, no!
How are we supposed to get the password?
Oh, I can bounce too.
Oh, it really does bounce.
Wait, that's so awesome.
And we're gonna be able to do a blitz next time probably,
which is great.
Wait, I have the ability to access the computer now.
Check Sunny's sunbeams, really?
Oh.
Wait, was this here before?
Is this... No, that can't be the password.
It's four?
They already have the password, just figure it out.
Is it like...
Like a B?
Eyeball?
E?
Pool?
T?
No.
Bept?
Bept.
Maybe that's kettle.
B...
B... K.
No.
Bept.
Why is it so bright?
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Almost got eaten.
Holy cow, that was scary.
Close.
Oh, dang, I'm close.
I'm using my brain.
Thank you guys for the help, though.
I'm glad I'm on the right track, at least.
I is E?
Oh, it's like a sounded out thing.
okay say this i i i thought it was like what it started with
okay okay okay um we're gonna save up for we'll do the
golden berry chance you know we're trying to collect the
rest of them so let's increase the multiplier a little bit
all right sound out each picture thank you guys Okay, let's
see.
B.
I.
Pool.
P.
Biped.
What is this?
Q?
Oh, B.
I.
Wait, maybe I.
Is this a pool Q, right?
Q.
I did it!
Star.
award-winning television producer reported missing Barry
Palmeroy a prolific and award-winning producer for the hit
nationally syndicated children show such oh that's the name
sunny time shop and the blanket for it has been reported
missing according to the authorities recently Palmeroy has
been working in the small town of Holloway Michigan
producing the new series Mrs. Rainbow Berry Patch Palmeroy
42 was last seen in the evening.
Creator and lead actress for Miss Rainbow's Berry Patch,
Donna Bellinger, confirms he had stayed after hours to
review, archive footage, and finalize materials for an
upcoming episode.
Are we?
Berry?
His car was discovered Saturday morning in the studio
parking structure, but Pomeroy was not present.
Mr. Pomeroy's disappearance is being treated as a missing
person's case, and Detective Alan Ortiz at this time, oh,
said Detective Alan Ortiz.
At this time, we are urging to contact the city's missing
persons unit.
Know your minute.
As a press time, production of Miss Rainbow's Berry Patch
continues.
The reruns are scheduled for the coming weeks.
We will update the story as new details emerge.
Big color comes to a small town.
Miss Rainbow's Berry Patch takes root.
If you've driven past the old Pulse and Canary...
Oh.
Wait, what's the order, though?
Oh, we got lots of stuff.
Oh, we gotta get the things.
We gotta get the stars to do the...
My fave.
Half blueberries, three strawberries, one peach, one kiwi.
Interesting.
Half blueberry!
Hmm.
Half blueberry.
Can I, like, saw it in half?
or something oh dang I didn't do literally anything and we
still made a decent amount of money it helps a lot if you
have the berry selector upgrade that's what I was exactly
what I was thinking it's a lot of money 300,000 dollars
we're at 50,000 dollars what oh we have 700 stars we should
we should upgrade some of our
Boing.
Can I upgrade you?
Wait.
What is it?
How much is it?
Why won't you tell me?
Oh no, our banana.
Oh, not enough, okay.
How much is it for the banana?
Can I please see a number?
800.
Oh, we're so close!
We can do that.
Come over here.
Eat the gnomes.
Oh, we want to do our multiplier too.
It's kind of difficult now because our...
The trampoline makes it so everything goes into the...
You know?
So we can only rely on our little berry buddies.
Eat the noobs.
Okay.
Maybe it's not wise to only upgrade one guy, but...
Whatever.
it's fine maybe wait did my trampoline get moved did I do
that drop it there we go oh come on so close yes yes please
you got this you got this you're so strong and capable it's
pro struts because then the bush starts like producing it
you know So it feels better to actually do it that way.
Wait, are these?
Is this working?
No.
Not even working.
Bus consumed!
Ah, dang it.
That's okay, though.
I'm hearing things, like, behind this wall.
I feel.
Hmm.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
The hole will become Elijah!
Oh, sheesh.
Oh my gosh, so scary.
Getting so close.
I don't want to lose my coins.
We're not making a ton.
It'll take us a couple days to...
get it, but I think we got it.
To get the berry chooser.
I also want to upgrade my vacuum capacity, though.
How many berries does it take to make a smoothie?
Well, probably the amount that is on the computer.
I imagine.
Oh, good, it stays.
The trash.
Oh, that's right, yeah.
The emails.
This is a studio-wide email.
We have once again reset the passcodes as we've noticed
multiple infractions from staff allowing friends family
visitors into the building after hours reminder this is not
allowed and puts unnecessary risk at the studio and all of
us who work here i get everyone in town is excited about the
show but any studio tours must be scheduled ahead of time no
exceptions do not tell anyone that that isn't a studio
employee the new passcode four two four one four is there a
place to put in a passcode was there a place lost in the
store thank you so much for this one he
Let's go, blitzin!
And wait, wait, wait, wait, I should have upgraded.
Wait, I should have upgraded my...
Where are you, banana?
Where are you?
I messed up.
All right, fountain!
We'll just wait until the next time we can do it.
I should have done the pineapple.
No!
Let me see.
So, wait, where was the security code?
Please let this be the last email I have to send about the
subject.
Donna, please disregard the previous email.
It was sent to the wrong recipient by mistake.
I apologize for the confusion.
Barry, you ultimately have the final say in how you run your
production.
If this is what you want, if this is what you think will
write the ship, we support your recommendation.
If there's anything else you'll need during this transition,
don't hesitate to reach out.
I wonder what happened.
Kiwi, peach, three strawberries.
Half...
It says half blueberries.
The hole grows larger!
Oh, I missed a pineapple.
No!
We did make a Buku Bucks this time, though.
Actually, I think we'll be able to get the...
Oh, yeah, we definitely can get the bush chooser.
Nice.
Almost lost it all.
Oh wow, I almost lost it all.
That was spooky scary.
Oh, golden pineapple!
Buku box, baby.
Alright, team!
How do I choose?
Random.
Oh, oh, oh.
Random from current buddies.
Oh.
So it was...
How many strawberries?
Three strawberries, one peach, one kiwi.
Oh, I need to move you.
Over there.
One, two, three.
Oh, I did four!
Okay, redo, redo, redo, redo, redo, redo.
Okay.
throw it in there oh my gosh wait look at all these
pineapples though
pineapples probably give us so much money okay oh shoot
alright let's do like one two three okay we'll move
everything over here one two two two three I don't know I
think it might have already been filled up though a little
bit yeah the chainsaw had some in it already dang it okay I
thought so there's already something in the chainsaw oh this
is tough
hello I wish I could oh there we go okay now it's empty
throw oh Oh,
we have to be so fast about it.
Yeah, this one is a pain.
Oh, my goodness.
We have to be pretty...
Oh, dang it.
We have to be pretty fast.
At least all the money is, like, right here.
So it's pretty easy to grab.
It'd be easier to bring the fruits to this chainsaw.
Oh, just...
Leave it where it's at.
Like, over there.
Okay, oh, we can try that.
My concern is the half...
The half blueberries?
Not quite sure how to do that.
Five blueberries, half the total.
Okay, okay.
Alright, it's just half the total for me.
Um...
Well...
Save maybe for...
Hmm.
Something.
I'll save for something.
Alright.
Let's throw that right there.
One.
Two.
Oh!
Three.
okay now change to it was one kiwi right one peach one kiwi
now now this is half a kiwi does that count or do I need
like another one five
blueberries wait a peach peach this is a peach it counts
okay all right and then five blueberries
Alright.
Oh, it'll be so easy to get the...
The golden ones too.
I'm going to become the Joker!
Why would you do this to me?
Snizzle!
Wait, didn't we need a golden strawberry?
No, I have it.
I need a golden blueberry.
Ah!
Snizzle, why?
Why would you do that to me?
Oh, yeah, I gotta hide it, I do.
I learned my lesson.
It was too easy.
That's fine.
We'll just make money this time.
I do want to make more stars, but...
Oh, I was hoping a golden blueberry would happen.
I got snizzled!
the whole expand at night.
It's kind of messed up.
What was that?
Oh, you guys heard that, right?
What was that sound?
Spooky.
Spooky noise.
Game too scary!
Wait, what was that?
Is that like a new lore in here?
There's so many tapes that we haven't gotten.
And all these...
Blurred out everything's.
You think the hole is haunted?
No way, Jose.
Couldn't be.
We're saving up for...
Oh, I said something.
I didn't actually decide.
We could do the cooldown.
Having more berry fountain would be great.
I mean, we make back that money from doing it, you know.
But then the fountain... Wait.
The fountain and the Blitz wouldn't match, you know.
Let's save up for Barry Blitz duration, because we do make a
lot of money from that.
Honestly, rewinding sounds kind of tempting, but...
I want to make this smoothie first, you know?
Alright.
Collect all objects before rewinding.
Yeah, that's true.
right yeah yeah if we even need to i mean we don't have to
because we'll get to five million trust trust
we'll save up for the berry blitz duration i think
all right you come here Keep you out of...
Okay.
Alright, what do I need?
I need...
Get my dang recipe back again.
Three strawberries!
Team, today we're not focusing on the cash.
We're focusing on another prize.
Okay.
One, two, oh.
Three.
Alright, this might have been a mistake, but we'll see.
one I think this was a blueberry yeah strawberry strawberry
okay one two three one peach thank you very much for your
patronage one kiwi
kiwi kiwi kiwi kiwi kiwi kiwi
Kiwi?
Wait.
Uh, throw you over there.
Oh, we make blueberries.
Wait, where'd it go?
Oh, there it is.
Kiwi!
I'm one blueberry?
Alright, we need five, right?
One.
Two.
Three.
Four?
I don't think we're gonna make it.
I don't think we have enough time.
Do I have to do the day?
Do I have to expand the day?
Oh.
Vacuum might speed it up.
Oops.
No!
Okay.
how much is a day oh 256,000 we can do that we can do that
we can do that
I feel like the suck is so fast that's the thing
yeah 20 seconds would really help a ton okay we'll save up
for that then next blitz will make it easy true I can't
believe we've already gone through like 90 90 um actually
we'll just do banana banana wait where's my why doesn't it
do a pineapple I have pineapple why want to give me my
highest berry
hmm that's my second highest lame depriving me of big
profits you'll That would be good if the saw is a bit
closer, I bet.
I'm just nervous about...
We'll- we'll see, we'll see.
I feel like I'm gonna sneeze.
Sorry.
Come here.
Bless you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
To be fair, banana is still a good amount.
Well, we'll accept the banana.
For profits.
Look, who's here?
Who's behind here?
Who?
What?
Snizzle!
Snizzle is always trying to sabotage me.
Snizzle is my biggest hater.
That's kind of a thank you!
We've already made it.
like so much money and more money though the trampoline
helps so much
snizzle saboteur that's literally his last minute how did
you guess
yeah oh yeah this is the good money this is the money they
talked about this is the money that that they only discussed
in legends did i get that yeah I think we need to kill
Snizzle.
Wait, will I have enough then?
Oh, we might, we might.
We might, we might.
Awesome.
I wish it were easier to see the whole...
Okay.
Yeah!
Our day length is extended.
And I'm gonna increase my vacuum capacity, because why not?
Will we be able to blitz?
Blitz!
We're gonna blitz first.
Yeah, we're gonna blitz.
Oh my god, it's all bananas!
Holy cow!
It's all bananas!
Wait, did I already put this in?
Oh, no, I didn't.
That's a lot of bananas.
Which means a lot...
Oh, I should have smoothies, huh?
Actually, let's do this.
Wait, I have an idea.
Make a smoothie?
Make a second smoothie.
Wait, did I make two?
Oh, you did it, did it, it did.
Oh, it doesn't...
Oh, it just...
Okay.
And fountain!
Yay!
Holy cow!
Oh, my prophets!
They're through the roof!
Wait.
Can I get up there?
I don't remember if I have peach or not.
Hello?
Why can't I fly?
Oh, I do have peach.
We have just one last left.
Our prophets are huge, baby.
This is insanity.
Wait, why didn't it get anything?
of these in here.
And it's still going.
Oh, I forgot I upped my...
Oh, gross large!
Oh, geez.
Gotcha, pulls, check.
Good luck with your pulls!
Thank you!
You too!
Oh my god, look at all the bananas!
We made half a million today.
Oh my gosh, you guys, we are so in.
It's still going even.
Like, it's still going.
This is craziness.
Okay, it stopped.
Finally stopped.
It's quiet.
So much profit.
That was so lucrative.
It was awesome.
I probably should have done the smoothies before I blitzed,
but that's okay.
Like, holy cow.
Guys, we're so back in business 600k don't fall in the hole
let's see i kind of want to pick up my auto coin but it's
fine right now what can we save up for
whole movement range maybe it's so much more it's
Honestly, the cool down would be crazy too, though.
Hammer, the sledgehammer.
We're in the money, a lot of money.
Doritos!
Welcome back, thank you.
That a wowie-zowie, a real wowie-zowie.
Juice multiplier?
Yeah, I think so.
I think juice multiplier would be big.
and we can save up for the sledgehammer
or maybe do the blitz duration.
I don't quite know which one I want yet.
There's so many good ones we could do.
You know?
Okay.
Alright, today's our day.
Let's put it right here.
Okay.
One peach.
Done.
Uh, Please move.
Um, no bananas anymore.
We need a kiwi.
A single kiwi, please.
Oh my gosh, I forgot I pick up so much more now.
Alright, one kiwi.
Run.
Alright.
Three strawberries.
Oops.
I picked them all up instead.
Alright.
One strawberry.
uh two strawberry throw uh three strawberry okay good good
one two oh i should have changed it to blueberry so i'd have
them dang it i forgot three all right blueberry blueberry
blueberry blueberry we'll just suck it up suck it up suck it
up you
clear it up a little bit clear it up clear it up Okay.
Oh.
That was close.
All right.
We got three.
One, two, three.
Uh, four, five, I think.
Four, five.
We got it!
We got the smoothie!
Run!
It's so spooky every time.
Yahoo!
Oh, collect the third black star.
Yeah, I did that.
Thank you.
I wonder if we can get the golden blueberry now.
We'll keep it on blueberries for a while so we can try for a
golden blueberry.
Try to get all the golds.
Check the office now.
Oh, you're right.
Wait.
Nothing changed.
what is this smooth moves cafe cashier ashley bagel smoothie
donna friend family discount
oh how do i oh it
said 1996 was that when it said that why what does the
receipt mean mysterious all right I think what we'll do is
I'm trying to decide if we want to go for golden fruits or
if we want to wow 500,000 let's go if we want to go for
golden fruits or if we want to go for um uh well I guess I
don't even have actually hmm We can do both.
We can go for golden fruits.
And we can go for stars because I don't even have the
pumpkin unlocked.
I know the shop music is so stinking cute, right?
Me, me, me.
Golden berry multiplier.
Let's do that.
We can just unlock that and get more cash money, baby.
Everything else?
We're starting to get to like millions, so.
Oh my god.
on so thank you how many is that now please thank you so
much yeah you know what let's do it again you're so right
thank you for the fit together thank you so much all right
so let's start absorbing things come come eat come come eat
come come eat i feel though we should probably not have our
blueberries since we're trying to get a golden blueberry we
probably shouldn't have it, you know bounce so move this and
let's make some smoothie
expensive smoothie oh there we go
oh nice it ate it
come come come come come come we need to put more stuff in
there Uh...
No golden blueberry yet.
Still on that lookout.
Wait!
What is that?
Could my eyes be deceiving me?
It's gonna get bigger I can feel it.
Wait, what is this?
That's a peach.
Still no golden blueberry.
Alright, we're trying to get to...
Um...
I don't know why I don't just hold it down.
Sorry, guys.
Um...
Wait!
Golden Blueberry!
We got it.
Alright, what else do we need?
I think... What is that?
Uh...
Watermelon?
Do we have watermelon?
Oh, it must be the plum.
It must be the plum, I think.
watermelon is the last one okay so oh so i thought they were
in order that's so confusing can i put can i put this back
ah ah ah yeah never mind oh it almost worked
okay could you not throw all my coins into the corner thank
you yeah plum makes sense i think it's the plum and then oh
And then, we made like no money today, but that's okay.
Good star progress.
Yeah, we got one thing.
I wish we could go up there and look.
Wait, so then it's pumpkin and then melon.
So I still have...
Several to...
Two more to unlock?
Dang, I thought I was just the pumpkin.
Yeah, you can walk through the process.
I have noticed that but you can't see the hole through them
so it scares me
I want to I want to do my vacuum capacity more so we can
make more money whole movement range is also pretty good
that would complete that circle I think so we'll do that
just kidding it extends of course it does yeah
I think it's this is definitely plum and then melanin and uh
oh wait we gotta move this again so we can get a golden one
we're just focusing on the goldins right now and also
getting more stars so let's go eat these eat consume consume
please thank you more stars and gold we got like kind of a
double mission going on you know double mission have you
found any cassette tapes I found a couple oh consume 500
props let's go yeah I've only found like a handful
oh nice can I get the houses I wonder
it's so annoying when it's everything is so far away though
that's why it'd be nice if we weren't getting the gold stuff
to use the trampoline but unfortunately we are attempting we
have two missions so oh oh um a little dicey maybe um oh oh
oh oh my goodness um we're getting some stuff uh get the
smoothie we can get the smoothie now oh god oh i think we
just got a house.
Nice!
Oh my gosh, a house in this economy!
Yahoo!
Oh, the smoothies don't go away.
Wait, can we push this house in?
Come on, come on now.
Come on now.
Yeah, don't be stingy.
Come on.
Come on!
You can do it!
Yeah!
We did it!
That was Snizzle's house?
Good.
That guy really tried sabotaging me multiple times.
I'm a Snizzle anti.
I don't even remember who my precious berries were before.
I didn't want favorites, but it ended up being that way.
We ended up sort of playing favorites a little bit.
Not on purpose.
Just some were more productive than others.
What can I say?
Smooth Moves Cafe.
When are these emails from?
Oh, wait.
There's another...
There's more emails.
Wait, but the whole cometh.
Donna, I understand your frustration.
Oh, this is also from 96.
I truly do.
Nobody besides yourself wants to see this show succeed more
than I do.
I believe we can make Barry Patch the house...
Whole name it deserves to be.
But to do so, we have to be realistic.
We need to make practical, rational changes to the
production to lower the cost.
I know we've been rehearsing the same conversation.
Oh, rehashing the same conversation over and over.
I understand you have a vision for this show.
You've put your entire self into it.
But this isn't my first rodeo.
I've seen many productions like ours go under just because
they refuse to make even the smallest of compromises.
Sorry, I'm checking for the whole.
Your vision is what makes this show special.
audience criticism and network heads that allow us to make
this.
No money equals no berry patch.
It's that simple.
The whole can't enter the door.
Oh, it can't?
Are you sure?
I don't want to get trapped in here.
Oh, you're right.
Awesome.
With that said, here are some places I think we can improve.
One...
The lighting is getting all funky.
Budget.
stop motion animation is too expensive does miss rainbow
need to be animated this way can we get a live actor costume
puppet there's concerns the jittery nature of our movements
is off putting to some viewers this is the tip of the
iceberg in terms of budget but we can discuss those
specifics later we're still receiving parent complaints that
the show is too scary do the humans have to become props to
learn their lesson it seems a bit too unsettling for our
audience can we find a a way to still teach the moral
without implying they're stuck like that.
Ha.
From Barry P. Yet.
Star Shine Studios.
So the props are former humans?
Wait, so we've been eating humans and gnomes?
What is this show?
Oh, let's watch, let's read this one too, since we have
time.
If You've driven past the old Paulson Canary lately and
noticed a splash of pastel paint and oversized fruit props?
You're not imagining things.
Halloway is officially home to a nationally syndicated
children's show.
Miss Rainbow's Berry Patch created by local writer slash
performer Donna Bellinger is currently being filmed right
here in town.
And while its journey hasn't been without bumps, excitement
is still much in the air.
I still can't believe we're doing this in Halloway,
Bellinger said.
During our visit to the set, I've been wanting to create the
show for so long and I'm beyond excited to bring my vision
to life and be able to reach and teach children all over the
country.
To be able to do it right here in Holloway, it's perfect.
The show follows Miss Rainbow, voiced by Bellinger herself,
as she tends a cheery berry garden alongside puppet
companions.
A mix of live action and stop-motion animation techniques,
berry patch focuses on pointed life lessons with a moral
each episode.
Local residents have been quick to notice the production's
presence with many halloweans enjoying the attention for our
small beloved community it's people despite the enthusiasm
miss rainbow's berry patch has faced early challenges since
its debut some parents have voiced concerns that the show's
tone can feel unsettling for young viewers oh this was the
90s right that's like the standard that's the that's the
standard for these types of tv shows oh my gosh don't show
them courage the cowardly dog 2.75 hour cannibal mark not
bad for a sicky ghost oh my gosh i can't believe it's almost
been three hours yeah oh my gosh you know what show
terrified me and disgusted me was rocco's modern life i
could not watch that show ren and stimpy all of those likes
those they i feel like they were So nasty.
Time flies when you're having fun, yeah.
Courage got me so scared when I was little.
Yeah, me too, but it was fun.
I love Rocco's modern life.
There was just something disgusting about it.
I thought Rocco was really cute, though.
What was he, a wallaby or something?
I thought he was cute.
But the show itself was disgusting.
Yeah, Ren and Stimpy was nasty.
I don't think Rocco was ever as gross as Ren and Stimpy.
I don't think I watched Ren and Stimpy.
Now I think about it.
Probably is what developed my humor.
Right?
Because, like, I don't like disgusting humor like that.
If you do, that's totally fine.
But it's not my cup of tea.
Ren and Stimpy was messed up.
So probably because I didn't watch...
I, like, binged...
Courage and the Powerpuff Girls.
So...
That was my everything.
Return to Slab.
I also liked Dexter's Lab.
Yeah.
But Powerpuff Girls was like my all-time favorite.
I would watch that every day.
And I would watch Nightmare Before Christmas every day.
To the point my mom was like, Stop watching Nightmare Before
Christmas.
I can't stand it.
It's not Halloween.
And it's not Christmas.
Dexter's Lab was my first favorite cartoon.
I loved Didi.
Didi, get out the middle of the laboratory.
It's just so funny.
I don't know I feel like TV shows back in the 90s I don't
know there was also like the live action shows like are you
scared of the dark and goosebumps and stuff like that these
parents are crazy there was so much crazy stuff on in the
90s what are they talking about what does this mean to do
that show gave me trauma which was Goosebumps?
Goosebumps show is so great.
Are you scared of the dark was my favorite?
That one I actually could not watch because it scared me so
much.
That one actually gave me nightmares.
I don't know.
Shows are not like what they used to be.
I think maybe probably the most, I would say the most recent
we got that kind of comes close is like adventure time
adventure time has some creepy moments some of the character
designs are pretty freaky did you sing back at your mom this
is halloween halloween halloween my sister and i used to
pick rolls to quote while watching nightmare before
christmas toy story too we watched it way too many times so
good so good oh gravity falls yeah gravity falls over the
garden wall oh yeah gravity falls such a good one too.
Yeah, I did have some screwed up stuff.
Tales from the Crypt!
I love Tales from the Crypt.
I love the Crypt Keeper.
I want to...
Yeah.
Crypt Keeper.
Twirling my hair.
Crypt Keeper, our Oshie.
Yeah, he's great.
Anyway, ratings for the first block of episodes have been
uneven.
Oh, wait.
Oh, sorry.
I'm a skeptic paragraph.
I don't think it's scary on purpose, Bellinger says, but I
don't talk down to kids.
Sometimes learning is uncomfortable.
Sometimes things feel strange before they feel safe.
Oh, that's so true.
You know what?
Like, I feel like shows like Sesame Street are pretty good
with that.
stuff like that.
Things that kids need to learn.
You need to process their feelings.
Yeah.
Ratings for the first block of episodes have been uneven and
industry sources confirm the production is operating on a
tight budget.
Yeah, Mr. Rogers.
Wee.
Yeah.
Sets are reused creatively.
Episodes are shot quickly and Belanger admits she often
stays late to make sure everything is just right.
about the criticism, Belanger paused before answering.
I listen, she said.
But I also trust my instincts.
This show means something to me, and I think in time it'll
mean something to the kids who stick with it.
I think this show would have, like, a cult following, you
know?
If it were real, like, people would be like, oh yeah,
remember that fever dream creepy show that we watch that
traumatizes us as kids?
Good times, good times.
Creep Adventures of Billy and Mandy So good I love that show
too I love I don't know I was one of those you know Creepy
kids Loved anything that was creepy like that I think a lot
of people in the 90s were You know It's exciting Bellinger
admits Even if the show is finding its footing The fact that
it's happening here in Holloway Feels special true and then
we read about the missing producer April 16th wait so our
oops no pick it up oh my bad April 12th and the smoothie is
a Donna smoothie that's so strange so this is just days
before this is like very yeah this is very close to when he
disappeared.
Yeah, now it says three out of seven.
Seven?
That's so many.
Now we can't press the start.
Smoothie order we did.
All right.
Sleep time.
What am I saving up for?
I can't remember.
Meep, meep, me, me.
We can do the...
Actually, I'm going to do the berry fountain cooldown.
Okay.
Maybe.
Did they turn Donna into a smoothie?
Oh, wait.
Did it say the cashier was April?
I guess so.
That would make more sense.
So Donna ordered the smoothie.
Yeah, I do have a Blitz for this day, which is great.
We're going to want a smoothie, then Blitz, then Fountain.
Cashier was at...
Okay, okay.
I think we want to just save up some more money a lot of
these are
change the bush to banana oh yes thank you all right all
right banana banana and smoothie baby smoothie smoothie come
on come on i need your apple thank you i need I need it.
I need it.
We're gonna smoothie.
All right, the blitz is ready.
Come on.
Come on, please.
Where's all the fruit?
Please!
We're so close, I need like one more.
Oh, there we go.
All right.
Where'd it go?
Oh, of course.
I went as far away as possible.
Oh, three times?
Blitz!
Blitz, blitz, blitz!
Oh,
it's over.
Uh, Fountain!
Alright, let's go eat this house.
Big money, baby.
Huge money, huge money.
And we keep getting more stuff, too.
Yeah, okay.
Nice.
I think I'm possessed whenever I hear the original version
of Minto's karaoke songs, I also hear Minto's voice singing
in my head.
Is there a cure?
I don't know.
The hole grows larger.
Yes, eat the house!
Eat the house!
So close.
Come on.
Get in there.
You're so close.
Uh, is it gonna get in there?
Maybe move over this way?
There we go!
I think!
Come on!
You're so close!
Oh please, please, please.
Come on!
This is so unfair.
Yeah!
Nice.
All right, then we can handle the other parts of the map
now.
We got everything over here.
I probably...
Holy cow, that scared me.
We wasted quite a bit of time.
I might need to actually increase my pickup range so that we
don't fall into the hole.
But...
Because it's like right there.
Ew, what was that sound?
That was scary!
What was that?
Um...
It was like...
Ooh.
Did you guys see that clip of like Hoshikawa from Nishisanji
watching Juju to Kaisen?
And then you hear this like creepy like in the background.
It gave me goosebumps.
It gave me...
It was so spooky!
It was so scary.
Many ghost sounds.
Spooky scary.
Okay, we're saving up for the sledgehammer.
But I do think we should maybe do the cool down and the
extend it so that we get more big money.
You hired her?
I do like her.
She hired a medium?
No way.
That's crazy.
The whole range could also be really good.
We did just upgrade that, though.
We'll save up for the sledgehammer.
We're already halfway there.
What are we eating?
We're eating the stuff over here.
Wait.
Yeah.
Go, my hole.
And we're also...
we're also making a smoothie oh no i think i'm over okay
good it's still reaching
oh nice there you are wait nice having it having the
trampoline is so nice because it like just shoots fruit so
the hole is always able to be moved it's really nice
actually so close oh come on oh come on oh come on oh come
on let's just get the car then just get the car yeah nice
okay now come over here we might be able to get the house
maybe oh oh oh oh oh wait wait wait it's being kind of
stubborn actually i'm also accidentally hitting q when i
don't mean to
It's trying, it's trying its best, for real.
The house.
So if you're wondering about the smoothie, I can't suck that
up.
Car get!
All right, let's see if we can upgrade our pineapple.
Where is he?
Pineapple!
There you are.
Can I upgrade you?
Oh, how much did it say?
I actually didn't see.
Probably 20...
Oh, 1600.
Okay.
Oh, there's so many pineapples here.
Holy cow.
Alright, hold.
Keep going, keep going.
Ah.
Maybe not.
Ah, so close.
Can't tell where it ends.
There it goes.
Okay.
1600 thank you guys thank you thank you
upgrade my others but we're trying to get to we're trying to
collect all of them I think we should focus on our one guy I
think we were getting one guide positive there's so many
golden in here
there's there's so much fruit over here it's kind of insane
so much of this potential oh there's a lot of money we're so
close to a million already though look at that
so many peaches peaches peaches peaches peaches we should
change our oh complete 100 days you're good at this at the
game Oh, it is bananas.
Okay, great.
This shit is bananas.
Wait.
And, and, and, yes!
Ah!
My bed.
Hey,
team!
Oh, uh, I need to move it back over there.
Go, go, go.
Wait, did I put it in the right?
It is moving.
I don't still know where the arrow is.
Oh, there it is.
Probably right there.
It's good.
Blitz in five minutes?
Where'd my...
Oh, there.
Oh, my God.
No, no!
Please!
The trampoline is sabotaging me too!
Everything is out to get me!
Oh, here we go.
Did I make one?
Just over here making his pineapples.
Did I make it?
Oh, I did.
I did.
Yuppie!
Okay.
Now we can start sucking.
It's so hard to tell sometimes.
There's just so much happening.
Oh, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yes.
Make more pineapples.
Yes!
There's so many.
Oh,
come on.
Oh, I can't get you both.
Uh, I care.
Um, like a little back.
Yahoo!
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Don't get eaten, don't get eaten.
Maybe we...
Oh, ah, we have enough!
We have enough to upgrade!
And also so many peaches over here.
It's kind of insane.
Nice.
We might have to upgrade tomorrow, though.
Wait, where do you go?
Oh, no.
No!
Okay, we upgrade tomorrow, maybe.
Or I can get him.
Yeah!
I got the achievement.
Buddy, buddy, buddy, buddy, buddy, buddy, buddy.
Make friends with a watermelon!
Oh, so watermelon isn't last.
Pumpkin is definitely last, then.
There's so much money.
There's so much cash over here.
Wait, I saw something glowing.
My eyes do deceive me, perhaps?
Suika!
Suika, Suika.
I didn't know this, but you know, like, there's a Suika card
in Japan.
That is the, uh...
Oh my gosh, I can't see the hole!
There it is!
I can't see the hole again.
He's like a little penguin, but I heard that they're
changing him.
To what?
A watermelon?
I don't know.
The penguin retired.
Why?
Nice, we made 400,000.
Holy, everything is able to be purchased.
Let's upgrade the sledgehammer.
Let's upgrade.
upgrade the blitz duration and next we'll do the fountain
cool down i mean they'll be having fun i'm having so much
fun hole is getting big hole is getting massive even
wait then so can we start tearing down these walls wait also
oh my gosh um no my oh that kind of just ruined our Oh!
Oh!
Yes, we can now have pineapple.
They are missing some.
Okay, I missed one.
They're people!
Wait, they're humongous now.
Wait, they're really big!
This was the last sledgehammer upgrade, wasn't it?
It was, okay, cool.
So this is the last one.
wall oh my gosh everything is huge though you know what this
reminds me of those like mobile game ads that's like you're
a hole and you go around the city and you you eat things and
you get bigger that's literally this game i play it on
youtube there's one on there's a version on youtube that i
play
we don't have... Sorry, Snizzle.
Because I don't have the trampoline.
Nothing is going to the hole.
I have to do it all manually.
But now we have melons.
Wait, no way.
Holy cow!
Oh my gosh, we can already get that!
That's crazy!
YouTube is best.
Yeah, honestly, I love YouTube games because thought they
were a scam at first but they're literally just the mobile
games and you don't have to ah thanks so close you don't
have there's no micro transactions yet it's kind of amazing
you get to play the games and like it'll be like oh you lost
you want to restart you don't have to watch an ad like it's
kind of really nice okay we didn't make so much money today
i mean we like there's our thing there's our black star oh
that's not another black star just kidding
oh i almost got all of it okay good yeah yeah like flash
games youtube as games and if you've ever seen like those
ads that you're like man this game looks kind of fun but i
don't want to download this app it could give me a virus or
there's probably like a million ads in it or whatever
whatever You don't have that.
Like, you could just play the game.
I did do a stream about it.
I did do a stream trying them.
And then I still play some of them.
I still play some of them.
Hee.
Alright.
Let's see how much our...
Uh...
How much we needed for our...
Watermelon.
You are how much.
How much are you?
I wish it was...
easier.
Oh, there he goes.
Oh.
Please.
Uh, 3200.
Okay, okay.
The hole is on the move, everybody.
The hole is on the move.
Probably find more tapes around here, too.
You need a golden melon, too.
That's so true.
Yeah, we have a golden pineapple, so we don't need to worry
about that for, uh, for the sake of
the trampoline and all that.
Eat it up, eat it up, eat it up, eat it up.
Actually, can you come here?
This thing's kind of in the way.
Oh, the blitz is ready, you're right.
Um, I guess, let's just do it.
And then we'll just fountain.
It doesn't even matter.
and we'll since stuff is going in there and fountain
oh my god oh my god oh my god nice thank you guys i didn't
notice wow okay 1500 nice nice nice nice consume 100 nooms
is the achievement i just got and we have more oh we have so
many pineapples So many pineapples.
Uh-oh.
Hmm.
How do we want to do this?
Yeah, you go in first.
You go in first.
That one.
Yeah, push it in, push it in.
Nice.
And we'll move over this way.
Get this house next.
Yes.
Keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going,
keep going.
Consume, consume, consume, consume, consume.
YAHOO!
There's so much fruit that I missed out on.
Does a trampoline redirect what you throw onto it?
I believe so, yeah.
I guess if I were, like, here, I could shoot.
And it, like, jump over.
I guess that's an option, isn't it?
What's this?
What's this glowing thing?
Oh, my gosh.
No.
I thought it might be a tape.
Just a numb.
Why is there a pineapple over here?
Saved it from walking.
Yeah, you're right.
I mean, I have just been kind of launching it from over
yonder, but okay, there's like so many coins to pick up.
Oh, did I just notice how much we made today?
We have to not fall into the hole.
It's priority number one at the moment.
Don't fall into the hole.
hole what was that ew i heard like i thought i heard a
person like go
ew creepy i think i got everything it's pineapple pineapple
yeah i think i got it all golden melon dang it we missed it
Oh, there's another golden melon!
Wait, oh, sorry, I thought it meant... I thought it was like
auto coin is just like everywhere.
It'd be awesome, but...
Okay, we have so much money.
We can upgrade to the tree!
I think it's time.
I think we upgrade to the tree, everybody.
I think it's- you get six berries.
That's double our amount.
Oh, it felt good.
And I'll do the vacuum capacity because...
Why not?
Alright.
How many stars do we have now?
Two... almost 2,000.
2,000 now.
We'll send our whole over this way the hole is on the move
please give me golden water melon golden melon golden melon
let's try let's try like launching things from the like if i
do this oh wow the strut I'm also...
Oops, alright.
Oh, no!
I just destroyed our golden melon!
No!
We had it!
I destroyed it!
My green!
There was no bounds!
Ah!
No!
Are we gonna get this?
Yes we are, let's go.
Wait, there's like a puzzle thing here.
Okay, we'll have to come back to that.
I broke something.
I heard it crash.
Oh, I heard something else crash.
Oh wait, I'm stupid.
I could be saving so much time.
Oh, nice.
Oh, apple.
Not melon.
I'm, like, on the lookout for it, you know?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Wait, we still haven't gotten our plum.
Ba-ba-ba!
We still haven't gotten our plum yet.
We can change the plum tomorrow.
Alright, let's move our...
Oh, shoot.
Uh...
Are these houses smaller or am I crazy?
Oh, dang it.
That's okay.
I will get our pickup though higher, I think.
Yes.
They look like playhouses.
I think they're smaller, no?
But we're almost at...
Guys, like we're growing exponentially.
It's kind of crazy.
I love how that's how these games work, you know, like
you'll They start kind of slow and then like when they build
up they go crazy in Thanos mode.
It's so fun Half a million easy now exactly We're crushing
it wait.
Oh, I meant to look in the office.
That was my bad Oh, I can't get the coin.
Okay, or the pickup.
That's fine
I think we might want to do the
You have to play shell diver then It's a one stream to
finish 100% game But 10 out of 10 Really?
I like snowballing numbers Me too!
It's so satisfying satisfying.
I can't tell if I want the Goldenberry March... Goldenberry
I almost said Markiplier.
Multiplier!
For the duration cool down.
Not the Markiplier.
Let's just go to the next day and then I'll decide.
Let's aim for...
Okay.
We're not profiting right now.
Today is not a profit day.
Today is...
Golden Plum Day.
Holy cow.
And, uh, get these tents day.
Alright.
Let's juice it up.
Juice it up.
Juice, juice, juice, juice, juice it up.
Yeah, juice it up.
Juice, juice.
Oh, that's a melon.
I thought it was a...
We got it!
We got it so fast!
Now we just need the one golden that we don't have, and
that's it.
Nice.
Oh, man.
Collection is almost complete.
We are nearing every fruit in existence.
What are you doing, Snizzle?
You are so useless!
Come over this way?
Eat.
Eat, eat, eat.
He wants to get fired.
He does!
He hates me!
I wish I could easily put the trampoline upright so that we
could like...
Oh, wow.
Whatever we did was awesome.
I don't know if we can get these trailers, though.
That seems a little ambitious.
We'll get this guy, maybe.
Actually, this might be ambitious, too.
We'll get all these tables.
Come here, come here.
Oh, never mind.
Will it fall?
I think one fell.
collecting the cash early.
We're cashing out.
I mean, I said it wasn't going to be a cash day, but look at
this.
We can't...
We are just printing money at this point.
We can't help but make money.
We're too good.
We're too good at making money.
Oh, when fell?
But I don't think it fell into my hole.
I don't think.
Every day is cash day.
We do have this puzzle to solve.
How exciting.
A puzzle.
Lore.
Lore, please.
Did I get everything?
I think I did.
I think I got it all.
Oh, there we go.
I didn't get it all.
Is there any more?
Any more?
How do I find more tapes?
I feel really stupid.
Does this open?
Oh, not that I can tell.
Maybe they open in the...
the daytime complete puzzles oh okay okay auto coin pickup
range I kind of want to do it oh but day length is so good
too oh everything's so good everything is like I'm like oh I
need this oh I need this oh I need this let me see if
there's another one okay there isn't okay our coin range is
like max out now don't forget the golden plum we got it we
got the golden plum now we're saving up for actually we
might have enough it was how much thirty two hundred thirty
two okay we're so close
all very good choices yes yes yes and we shall get them all
yes come here Throw!
All right.
Let's do more of this area.
Let's clear it out.
Yes, good, good.
So many fun apples.
Soon we will have melons on our tree, a melon tree.
Can you believe it?
Oh my god, there's so many peaches in here.
We can take a look at this puzzle even.
Trying to see what it's about.
Oh.
Are you gonna go in?
There we go.
Nice.
We'll just get all this.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
They're trying to escape.
Oh no.
Sorry.
You won't live.
way there we go no escape it's kind of brutal and
the walls come tumbling down in the city that we
many golden go fire fire fire
does it almost feel like nothing's changed oh yeah look at
this this actually the auto pickup was a huge oh my god this
saves so much time oh my god oh it feels so good is there
anything over here i guess not oh we just need to like graze
it barely like it's awesome nice nice oh and we can upgrade
to pumpkin tomorrow pumpkin time is happening okay what is
this increase the Growth multiplier.
Increased day length.
I feel like it's so good.
We can absorb so much more stuff, you know.
I'll do that.
It's not even October.
Thank goodness.
I like...
I like once spring, you know.
Make friends with the pumpkin!
To 9,999 stars.
Can you even get that many?
Surely not, right?
Surely, that's...
There's not even enough to suck, no?
Snizzle.
Trying to get my secrets, huh?
I'm gonna send the whole that away.
And we're gonna go check out what's going on over here.
Oh, yeah, we can upgrade the fruit on the tree!
All right, all right, thank you.
Ta-da!
Oh.
What is this now?
That's when I contacted the police.
I explained I had just returned to the studio to find the
ransom note and buried nowhere to be found.
A ransom note?
Wait blue pin equals submit.
Wait can I...
Okay.
Triangle square circle.
They just said that he disappeared.
Nothing about a ransom note.
Whatever is happening over there.
Something is happening over there.
I think we need to move our hole a little bit.
Something is happening here.
Can we scoot you over this way?
little bit.
But maybe this way.
Maybe we need something to push it in, you know?
Or no, it's pushing others away.
No, don't push me out.
Don't push me out.
Okay.
Oh, oh, she did.
Oh, she worked.
She worked.
Yeah.
They all succumb to the hole.
They all succumb eventually.
Is this a golden pump?
No.
It's not.
Sadly.
I thought I was like, oh my gosh, is it time already?
You might need the hole to solve that puzzle.
Oh, true, you're right.
Oh, so many of our things didn't make it in because it was
blocked.
Oh well.
It's okay when you still made good money.
We're still back to a million?
Ransom note.
I wonder if there's now, like, a new email.
No.
Trash?
Oh, no.
We need all the stars for that.
Blitz is ready!
Thank you!
Actually, then, let's do blitz duration.
Since we're in a...
12 seconds is $48 million.
That's more than the star key!
That's crazy!
All right, so what we'll do is we will juice.
We'll smoothie.
Juice it up, juice it up, juice it up, juice it up.
Come on, everybody.
Production time is here.
I think one more.
Two.
There we go.
Okay.
Let's go!
Oh my god.
Wait, we probably can get a...
I see her!
Got all the golden!
Fountain!
I wonder if it'll level up our hole.
I did.
Guys, it's kind of insanity right now.
It's kind of insane right now.
I think we just focus on the cash then.
We could do several upgrades like this.
Don't fall in.
Somebody was sabotaging me.
Snizzle!
Snizzle was sabotaging me.
Once again, throw him in the hole.
And we pick up the money instantly.
Yeah, it's like kind of insane.
Our setup right now is like super crazy.
I think we can probably upgrade some of our peach guys too.
So we don't have so many peaches happening around anymore.
How much time do I have left?
Oh, let's take the hole over there.
I want to see if we do need the hole for that puzzle.
We might have enough time.
We'll see.
And not... that's okay.
Yeah, almost two levels.
It's kind of crazy.
I mean, we could still use the trampoline.
It is upright.
Oh, go here, go here.
Oh, it does show!
It does show!
The lines!
Oh, I see it, I see it!
Okay.
Alright, so we'll need to bring that.
Seven million dollars.
Slight profit.
Wow.
Maybe 48 million is not like so crazy to think about, huh?
We could get the key!
Is that gonna end the game?
The key to happiness?
I'm gonna get our juiced up.
Whole movement will do that too.
It's end ending.
So there's more- so I figured there would be multiple.
Because we have the- I'm gonna get the black stars though.
You know.
chance.
We'll do the multiplier.
And we'll do the multiplier again.
Holy cow!
Sixty million!
But it's so worth 22 times the multiplier is crazy.
Endings do not reset progress.
Oh, really?
We could get it tomorrow, then.
We'll do the cooldown.
And we'll do the cooldown again.
Oh, I should have done the bonus growth.
That's okay.
I don't think we'll have a...
You need more fruits.
Oh, we're getting there, buddy.
We're getting there, buddy.
The fruits are happening.
Oh, let's juice up.
Ew.
I don't know how I feel about a pumpkin in my smoothie.
I don't know.
In my fruit smoothie.
Hmm...
Alba!
Love you, Alba.
Wait.
Is that my smoothie?
Yes, it did.
Alright.
Oh wait, where'd my hole go?
Where'd my hole go?
Oh, he's all the way over here.
Come here.
Come here, silly goose.
What are you doing over there?
A little bit of pumpkin spice never hurt anybody so do i
have to oh my gosh do i have to see how many are like
connected to one two three four five wait okay one two one
two three four it stops what
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Let's go this way.
This is so confusing.
Eight!
How am I supposed to know?
Wait, I'm confused.
Do you want a hint?
Yes, please.
please yes please hint oh my gosh there's so much let's
cheat yeah blue is the end point i think it says that though
it didn't it i think i just was stupid and forgot about it i
think it did say that didn't it like on the little thing
we were gonna do the bonus growth we'll do the berry the
golden berry chance we'll up that we'll up our movement my
vacuum capacity
you can fly above for a better view oh you're so right
said blue to confirm let's go see let's go see what it said
real quick we'll send the whole like right here to eat the
No, like, over there.
There we go.
Blue pen equals submit.
Boing!
Hello?
I wish there was, like, a power for my, uh, for my sucker.
Because, um...
We could at least, like, you know...
Oh yeah, upgrade buddies.
Thank you.
I forgot.
I wanted to upgrade some of my peaches.
Snizzle?
You are curse of Apple.
You will never be upgraded.
Oops.
Who are you?
June!
Hard work in June.
Wait, 800.
I think we can do another to a...
Ha!
Who is that?
Oopsie!
June the OG.
June was our girl.
And now we have not so many beaches.
And we have, like, half time.
Football fever.
Alright.
I'm scared of going up and falling into the hole.
Can I...
I can control the hole while I'm in the air.
Oh my goodness, it's so scary.
It's hard!
One, two, three, can I turn off my flashlight?
Four, five, six.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
That was square, right?
That was square.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Wait.
One more.
Six, one.
Say the line, but y'all never catch me!
You'll never catch me!
I won't satisfy you and your greed.
Ah, dang it.
Okay, awesome.
Alright, everybody please remember that square is seven.
I think we'll probably...
Well, I could be fast maybe for the other ones, but...
Square is seven.
Do I want another berry buddy?
Why not?
They're just so darn cute.
We'll max out our berry buddies.
They're just hanging around.
I think everything else, well, this one is, and this one is
saveable.
Everything else is like totally ridiculous pricing, though.
Cold movement speed is doable.
That one's doable.
Okay.
Square is 7.
What if I just reset it all now?
Alright, so Goldenberry Chance.
We'll aim for increased juiced growth multiplier.
Or Goldenberry might be more feasible for next...
Blitz Hour.
Alright, go my hole!
Go!
Go my- Ah, you guys are so cute!
I just like a little...
I'll upgrade you immediately.
What's your name?
What?
Umberley!
And Queenie!
Queenie, you're now Raspberry Queenie, you're now a
Strawberry Queenie!
I dubbed the Kiwi!
Queenie the Kiwis.
Too cute.
I like knocking him over.
What are you, a strawberry now?
Oh wait, you're the same as Snizzle.
Wait, so Snizzle's been a... Wait.
No, you're an apple.
No curse of apple for you.
Oh, shoot.
Curse of apple for you.
Okay, come back, Cole.
We're gonna do...
circle no we're gonna do triangle one two three four five
six does it go this way or that way eight not okay no it
goes that way so because it doesn't connect what was it
started here right one two three four five
Six.
All right, triangle is six.
Okay.
Circle.
One, two, three, four, five.
No, I did it wrong.
Maybe it's just four.
Wait, but then...
Maybe this is...
Two, three, four, five, six.
Maybe this is five, then.
What?
Wait.
I was wrong.
Oh, I was wrong.
You only...
Ah!
Okay.
I think maybe then it is one up.
Shoot.
Wait, what was it then?
Wait, I can check.
So, five.
Okay.
One guess a day.
It was like that before, I remember.
Gosh, I can't stop making money.
Saving up.
Fountain Blitz ready, smoothie ran out.
Thank you!
We'll do that real quick then.
Do the bigger fruits, like, fill up your meter faster?
Chainsaw is like literally humping the trampoline.
It's kind of insane.
Oh, okay.
It's good.
All right.
Blitz!
Fountain!
The whole crowd is larger.
Alright, so 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Please be right.
No!
What did I do wrong?
I counted...
Hmm.
I already tried the minus one on each.
Huh.
What the?
Why is this driving?
Wait.
Oh!
It disappeared.
No!
The hole grows larger again already?
What is that door?
Oh wait, that must be where the star key goes, right?
Ghost taxi.
Actually, though.
Oh, we have a smoothie here.
Oh, it's just making stuff on its own.
Good job, good job.
Yes, take it down.
The hole grows larger.
Oh, there's like a little clock.
Okay, there's another puzzle here.
Oh, okay.
The clock is important for the puzzle.
We might be able to get this in, too.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Before that, it didn't even fit.
That's crazy.
The clock said no.
Not today, I just like noped out.
Gotta be careful here.
I don't know where the hole is.
That like only outlines some of it.
So it's kind of stressful.
Yeah, I think our hole is like nearing completion.
I don't know what that means.
But it just seems right to say.
What is this puzzle then?
Someone wanted to just spoil it for me.
I don't feel like counting it again.
Oh, my gosh!
That's crazy!
Hold on, I'll look it up.
Thank you!
You mean it's almost...
Oh!
Wow!
So let's keep juicing.
Come here you!
Here?
You do your job.
Let's go check out what this clock is.
Do you go somewhere?
You're looking at me all sussy like.
Do I place you somewhere?
Do I have a smoothie?
I have a smoothie?
Do you get placed in like one of these places?
I don't want to make much sense, but...
Wait, is it going by now?
The time changed.
Yeah, you're right.
Oh wait, there's a tape here!
I poisoned Barry's coffee.
It was quicker than I thought it'd be.
His mug clattered to the floor as he collapsed.
We have an old orchestra pit below the soundstage.
We repurposed for the puppeteers and prop storage, so I
dragged Barry over, lifted the trap door, and scooted him
in.
I figured I had a few days tops before someone found him, so
I tossed in a few more props, some gnomes, flamingos, that
sort of thing, to cover him a bit.
Um, Donna!
What the hell?
Wait, okay, but also it was like a countdown, the clock was.
I think we lost our chance for it today.
Yeah, it's not moving anymore.
Liar, liar!
Wow, so shiny!
Where's Barry?
It un- it un- it unhid.
It un-pixelated.
My dojinchi.
Pin puzzle is 478.
Thank you.
What?
How did I get that wrong?
I feel like I counted it properly, but I'm...
Obviously I didn't.
Thank you so much.
478.
Sorry.
I just don't feel like counting it.
It's not even...
It doesn't even feel so much like a puzzle as it is just
like an annoyance.
You know what I mean?
Well,
dude, those speeds.
The triangle one didn't stop where you thought it did, it
went slightly beside that pin.
Ah, makes sense.
Three, four.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Dang it, I did it.
I said it.
My bad.
Ah, thank you.
All right, let's eat these.
She said the thing!
Collect Black Star number six.
It was six!
How many were there?
Keep eating, keep eating.
You're so hungry.
Keep eating, there we go.
There were seven in total?
Wait, but...
Oh, okay, we're on five, just kidding.
Oh, oopsie.
There's so many fruits here.
It's kind of unmanageable.
Drowning.
We're suffering from success.
The multiplier goes crazy.
It absolutely does.
We'll do...
Okay, so I remember the clock one, and then there was one
over here.
I believe.
I don't have much...
Oh, I have time.
Just kidding.
Here, we'll do this real quick.
Send all that over.
Alright.
Let's go check it out.
Believe it was behind here.
Or... right here.
But there's like nothing here.
Do I just eat this?
Hmm.
I need to eat the ghost taxi.
When does it come through?
Ghost taxi Is that really what unlocks it?
It's so far away though
Oh, come on You guys are jerks Oh, come on, come on Was
it a million?
That's not so bad then Which is crazy, I'm saying that Holy
cow, one million Whatever Me to our money i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm sorry
i wonder when the taxi comes in if it'll like avoid our uh
oh this song is nice if it'll avoid the hole i
figured that had to do it with something though you know
it's not just gonna come driving on through or no for no
reason Alright, let's get some salsagers.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, eat the people, eat the people.
Eat the people, eat the people.
Eat the people.
We can get this guy too, probably.
Uh, uh, yes.
we absolutely can the time one is stumping me a bit
oh i heard it wait where'd it go i heard it though i heard
it it went and then it sounded like it screeched away or
something there it was it was a little off of my predictions
of where it would end up
think about where the clock spawns okay thank you for the
hint
i'm actually so hungry for my dinner i should eat soon oh
but i want to finish the game i'm having so much fun oh my
gosh it's been four hours you guys let's let's put the hole
on our top of it and see what happened well it did like
shoot it up into the air didn't it Does it do anything else?
Go eat.
Yeah, I will.
I can't believe we missed the stinking taxi by like...
By like the tiniest margin.
It was right there.
She is driving right next to me, isn't she?
Wait, where'd it go?
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
That was kind of freaky.
I don't know, guys.
Should we just get the key?
But I want to see the dark star ending.
So bad.
We have one.
Two tapes left?
Oh, no.
Quite more.
Uh, one.
Wait.
Oh, we're missing so many, actually.
He might be high?
What are you eating for?
dinner this i've had sushi sounds good i don't know what's
for dinner i don't know what to eat oh wait we have berry
300 000 in unmarked bills dead drop midnight wednesday oh
wait wait we have one here that was about where my original
plans ended i paced around the office before an idea struck
me i fabricated a ransom note surely that would lead the
police away from the studio pit, at least long enough for me
to figure out a long-term plan.
I walked the three miles to where my car was parked and
drove back to the studio.
Donna, what are you doing, girl?
What are you doing?
Oh, the pots are knocked over.
Oh, no!
Everything is going, everything is getting bad!
Oh, here we go.
We have Barry.
$300,000 in unmarked bills.
Dead drop midnight Wednesday Humboldt Park no cops We're
watching He was already dead That's crazy That's crazy work
Goldenberry chance Oh Are there more emails?
Oh that's a great question I'll check tomorrow night Just
try to remind me Yeah Barry was already juiced Yeah all
right we have a lot more over here oh wait actually i want
to try and get the car we'll just we'll just camp for it
like hereish we're just gonna camp for the car and make more
money the plot thickens because the more uh stuff we figure
out and for like the plot like the more these puzzles we do
the more plot we get which is fun exciting i love plot okay
that should be about it right oh the blitz thank you
make such unsettling sounds and fountain
holy don't knock me in don't knock me in Whoa, those are
some big coins.
Ah!
Please!
Get him, get him, get him.
Got him!
We got him!
The hole grows larger.
Wait, so then if I go check back over here...
Go as taxi, get it!
Is there another one to get?
Do I have to get them all at the same time?
Like the same run?
Oh my goodness.
Just come, come whole.
Come over here.
Eat all of this.
I don't want to deal with it.
I think it was, I think Taxi was the clock.
Oh, you're right!
Wait, it's floating up.
Come back?
There we go.
Nice!
Did you guys hear that?
Wait, there was like a...
Something made a sound.
It was like a radio.
It was like a...
Like a cop, you know, like a cop radio or something.
Let me know, by the way, if I try to keep the volume up
because the tapes themselves are pretty...
or pretty low volume but if the game is loud just let me
know I'll try to remind I'll try to be like I had been
turning it up and down but I just kind of left it up from
now
13 million
oh I heard another creepy sound it was like a gargling sound
I wonder if that's the sound of the people you know Wait,
where am I?
Oh, here we go.
Like, if I'm hearing...
Oh, here's another one.
Shortly after, I took a taxi back to the studio, dropping me
off a few blocks away in case anyone saw me.
Parking receipt.
Oh.
So...
Oh, there's another one.
We wrapped around 2.30 p.m.
errands but I'd be back later to chat.
I drove my car out of the studio parking lot around 3 p.m.
I drove to my usual smoothie shop and parked in the paid lot
nearby making sure I kept the receipts for my alibi.
There's blood on the ground or oh maybe not maybe that's
just a stylistic choice of the... alright let's check the
emails.
There are more emails!
This one.
Dear Ms. Bellinger, I want to personally thank you for
taking the time to speak to us regarding the note you
discovered at Starshine Studio.
Your cooperation is extremely helpful as we continue our
investigation into Barry Pomeroy's disappearance.
I also need to ask again that you refrain from discussing
the matter with the media or posting about it publicly.
Cases of this nature tend to pique the public interest, and
any disclosure of the note's contents or your discovery
could inadvertently place Mr. Pomeroy in greater danger or
compromise the investigation.
Your assistance and discretion are greatly appreciated.
If you notice anything else unusual or receive any further
communications related to this matter, please contact me
directly at this email or my direct line.
Thank you again for your cooperation.
Sincerely, Officer Marlene Simmons, Holloway Police
Department.
And there is no articles.
Oh!
investigate possible arson after Starshine Studio Fire.
Authorities are investigating the possibility that last
week's Starshine so hard to say Starshine Studio.
I am gonna hydrate.
May have been intentionally set following preliminary
findings at the scene.
Did she set the fire to?
The Blaze which broke...
Sorry.
broke out shortly after 11 30 p.m.
Tuesday caused extensive damage to the majority of the
studio's interior fire crews were able to prevent the flames
from spreading to nearby structures and no injuries were
reported however investigators now say the fire's origin and
burn patterns have raised concerns there are indicators that
suggest the fire did not start accidentally said fire chief
mark rustwick during a Wednesday afternoon briefing we're
not prepared to make any conclusions at this time, but we
are treating this as a potential arson case.
Starshine Studio, a soundstage and production building in
South Holloway, has recently been the site of local
television production Miss Rainbow's Berry Patch, the
children's educational TV show.
The building's east wing, which housed offices, tape,
storage, and soundstage, sustained the most severe damage.
It covered the evidence that he got poisoned.
The fire occurred just one week.
after the disappearance of Barry Pomeroy.
Sorry.
An award-winning producer connected to the project.
I might be reaching my limit.
As well as the acclaimed series, Sunny Time, I almost said
Sunny Time Slop.
And the blanket fort.
Sunny Time Shop.
As of this post, no new details have emerged on the
whereabouts of Pomeroy.
Law enforcement officials would not comment on whether the
two incidents are connected.
the title of the next article, and I'm like, uh-oh.
We are aware of the timing, said Detective Alan Ortiz, at
the stage where exploring all possible angles.
Among the destroyed areas were tape archives and
post-production facilities.
Despite the extent of the damage, one VHS tape was found in
what appears to be pristine condition.
Ortiz said, it was located in an area that otherwise
sustained heavy fire and smoke exposure.
Ortiz cautioned against drawing conclusions.
oh my gosh okay media degrades differently depending on
storage conditions he explained there are a number of benign
explanations for why an item like that might survive the
tape which had no visible external damage has been logged
into evidence and will be sent to an external lab for
analysis at the stage we're treating it as a potential piece
of evidence nothing more Ortiz said given the circumstances
it could also be a prank or something planted after the fact
exciting when asked whether the tape could be connected to
Barry Pomeroy's disappearance Ortiz declined to speculate
this doesn't feel like bad luck anymore said one resident
who lives near the studio first a man vanishes then the
building burns somebody wanted something gone as the
investigation continues the once colorful studio now sits
blackened and cornered off an uneasy symbol of something
unearthed in Holloway but did they watch the tape It does
feel like it was planted.
That's my thought.
Police investigating string of disappearances.
Oh my gosh, this one's also long.
Holy cow, this one's really long.
Okay, okay.
Thursday, August 7th, 1997.
So about a year later?
Or a couple months later, this all happened in...
No, over a year.
Over a year later.
Holloway authorities are investigating a growing number of
missing persons cases that appear to be connected by
disturbing common detail a single VHS tape recovered from
the starshine studio fire is it a cursed tape
according to police at least 11 individuals reported missing
over the past year and a half and a half were seen in
locations where the same tape was reportedly found inside a
VCO The tape identified as the locally produced children's
program Miss Rainbow's Berry Patch has had previously been
logged into evidence after being recovered intact from the
burned out studio building.
Raising additional questions.
Missing individual shared occupations associated with
children, including a librarian, a daycare worker, and most
recently a kindergarten teacher.
Why?
They didn't do anything wrong!
Yeah, Sotako chill, girl.
Detective Alan Ortiz, who is overseeing the investigation,
said the pattern has prompted serious concern though he
urged the public to remain calm at this point we believe the
tape may be serving as a calling card Ortiz said that
suggests an individual or possibly a group attempting to
link these incidents together complicating the investigation
is in fact is the fact that the tape itself is no longer in
police custody how did that happen how is it all the people
that I've been eating Ortiz confirmed that the HS cassette
went missing from evidence lockup less than 24 hours after
it was removed from the studio fire site okay that's very
fast an internal review came up inconclusive as how the tape
was accessed and by whom we're treating that as a security
failure Ortiz said there's no indication at this time that
the tape was mishandled intentionally by department staff
but we have tightened our procedures so this will never
happen again as to how the tape continues to elude police
hands, Ortiz explained.
In every instance so far, the tape was reported present by
whoever discovered the scene.
We rely on witnesses to tell us what they saw, and when our
personnel arrive, it's gone.
That's the gap.
That's the gap we're focusing on.
That tells us the removal likely occurs in the window
between the first discovery and when our officers arrive.
Well, yes?
What else would it happen?
Okay.
yeah yeah that's how time works yeah exactly uh he's like
he's like in my actually in my very astute deduction the
tape goes missing between when the witness views it and when
we arrive so therefore it must go missing within that time
that's what i've deduced yeah sherlock holmes everybody A
big round of applause.
Somehow a cursed tape where an upset showrunner named Barry
who died with Stummy Hort doesn't hit the same.
Well, what do you mean?
He died of poison!
He got poisoned!
In each of the recent disappearances, investigators found no
signs of forced entry or struggle.
The only consistent element was the presence of Miss
Rainbow's Barry patch tape already loaded in the VCR.
Ortiz stressed the but this does not mean the show itself is
responsible.
This is not about the content of a children's program, he
said.
Physical objects are often used symbolically in crimes.
We've seen it before.
When a case gets this much national attention, it's not
unusual to see copycat behavior.
While authorities say there is no indication of immediate
danger to the general public, police are asking residents to
remain alert.
Ortiz encouraged anyone who finds tapes, recordings, or
promotional materials related to Miss Rainbow's Berry Patch
to contact police immediately.
If you find what you believe to be that tape or anything
tied to the production, do not play it, Ortiz said.
If it is some kind of warning, some kind of calling card,
your safety may be at risk.
Report it immediately.
As the investigation continues, authorities say their focus
remains on establishing a timeline, identifying who had and
continues to have access to the tape and determining whether
the disappearances are the work of a single offender or
something more coordinated.
Anyone with information related to the missing person's
cases, the VHS tape, or Miss Rainbow's Barry Patch is urged
to contact the Holloway Police Department.
Oh,
don't look at that.
It's really funny that, like, things are unlocking.
Ah!
Sorry.
That scared me.
Hi!
scared me nice shoes
um things are changing but there's just a big old melon in
here sorry that's what i was in the middle of saying also my
bed is covered in melons too oh that one that one got me uh
we'll do the whole movement range And we'll, like, what can
we save up for?
All of these are, like, crazy expensive.
So we'll just do that again.
We'll do my vacuum capacity.
We'll do it again?
Okay.
We've almost gotten all, like, the ones that are...
doable, so...
What was I working on now?
Oh, my gosh.
That one got me.
Spooked me.
Nothing else has changed, it seems, though.
Alright!
So...
Um, we'll send you over there.
Go forth my hole!
Consume all that is...
here.
I'm curious what we have to do for this one.
It's like kind of hidden.
Like you don't know it's here until you like, you know.
Eat the gnome!
There he goes!
Oh my gosh, Rainbow Star!
Oh, oh, sorry, my finger's slipping.
We're like getting everything now.
Yeah!
What if we have to like eat these trailers?
And that's the puzzle.
Uh...
Uh, go that way?
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh!
Oh, um, uh...
So close.
Oh, so close.
You got this?
Yes!
You got this!
The star can't even get out.
Wait, uh...
Go back this way?
No, now...
Oh!
Oh my god, we did it!
Let's see what happens when the hole goes over this star.
Nothing.
Huh.
All-consuming hole.
We're seriously like going crazy with the stars now.
Yay!
Oh, let's get this house?
Oh, and this little area right here.
I don't even know how much time we have left in the day.
Tiny little thing, yeah.
And all we have is this stuff on the other side, and that's
it.
Alright.
It's still...
I mean, I didn't think it would be so easy to just, like,
you know, eat that, and it would, you know,
You missed something to be seen.
Yes, clearly.
You can definitely get the 9,000 to upgrade.
That's true.
We could get the 9,000 to upgrade the pumpkin.
Should we?
That's kind of exciting.
Wait, that's really exciting.
Oh, hey.
Run away.
account got suspended for liking too many meat to art.
I hope I can get it back to you.
I hope you can too!
Thanks for liking them though.
I'm glad you like so many, you know, the fan arts.
The fan artists are kind of insane.
They're so awesome.
Phone rings.
You pick up.
The voice on the line says, do you like Fruity's children's
shows?
Nothing else has changed in here though that we see.
No new emails or such.
We could get the vacuum capacity.
But right now I'm just focusing on eating.
Go!
My hole!
Oh, watch out.
Watch out my hole.
Oh, wait, shoot.
We need you.
We need you like right here.
Please.
Okay, good enough.
Yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Perfect, perfect.
We need it so that it will keep the hole from...
Like, we need the fruits to keep going so that we can keep
the hole moving, you know?
Let's actually...
No, we'll get all this pot.
All the pots.
Be them up, be them up, be them up, be them up!
Check on your friend in the castle.
She's still chilling.
Still chilling.
Oh!
Oh, it's wobbly!
Oh.
Come back.
Come back a little.
Wait.
Sometimes it's hard to place the arrow.
I just kind of like guess.
There's so tiny parts.
Oh.
Over here.
We are close to 9,000, aren't we?
Maybe we will actually.
be able to.
I wonder what we get after that though.
What do you get after pumpkins?
What could be larger than a pumpkin?
It's over a hundred thousand!
I love ancient memes.
Wait, we might actually... Two pumpkins?
That's just Sounds greedy, egregious.
Just trying to see what I'm missing there.
This one might be kind of tough.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
No, maybe next time.
Maybe this time.
Maybe next time.
Alright, let's collect our earnings.
Or even is the hole.
Oh no, I can't see it.
Oh, it's over there, I think.
Gotta be careful.
Pumpkins and more pumpkins.
I think I got everything.
Hmm.
I have just a few tapes left.
Other pumpkins are in here!
What are you doing in here?
Goofball.
Let's just keep going.
All your base or belong to us is the meme that predates
memes that comes to mind when I think about it.
Of like ancient, ancient memes.
Yeah, that's a pretty old one.
I mean, it's a classic though.
It's like an actual ultimate classic.
We might be able to upgrade our pumpkin today.
Let's get, like, over here.
Maybe.
Come on.
Just a little...
Why is it going up?
Oh my gosh.
We're actually so close to 9,999.
Okay.
Stop going up!
What are you doing?
Where are you doing?
Were the coins pushing it?
Oh, you think so?
I'm suffering from success once again.
Okay, I think to get the...
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh, it's so close!
Oh, yeah, the coins are definitely pushing it.
That's so funny.
Oh, the gnome dial.
Hi, gnome.
Alright.
Consume all gnomes!
Oh!
I killed that.
I took them all out.
I took them out.
Nice.
Our blitz is almost ready.
Will we have time to do it?
Maybe today.
We might have time.
I don't want to waste it, though.
I'll save it for tomorrow.
I think it would be safer.
Check the room?
Because we ate all the doves?
It's so sad.
That truck can go in.
And I think the garbage can can too.
How is it so much money?
Like never-ending flow.
Oh,
I think it's the same issue.
The coins are suffering from success.
That's okay.
I'll collect my earnings.
and we
I don't even have to do much to generate so much money like
imagine if I tried how much money we could have
I think I got everything though yeah
hmm does not look like anything oh what is this
disk disk Just got back from Project...
Oh, Project Hail Mary!
Wait, wait, wait, I want to see it.
Wait, one second.
Hope you're having an amazing day!
Did you like it?
I loved it.
Raymack thanks to...
Oh, sorry I didn't see who raided me.
Thank you!
Hello, hello!
Goi nasaimasu!
Go shi tsa mao jesawa!
Raymack thanks for the gifted!
Thank you, shiitai.
Thank you for the gifted!
Norgo, thank you for the five gifted!
Raymack thanks for the gifted!
Jay!
Thank you for the gift!
the park at the thank you thank you thank you hello
everybody we're playing berry berry berry where sandbox.exe
where we have a hole and we just make it big big big and we
get lots of money
oh what did i just do i forgot what control does i was
trying to crouch is there a crouch there's no crouch oh
sorry can
i join oh sorry oh Sorry.
Oh!
I'm trapped?
Uh...
Oh!
Well, it's multiplying.
Woo!
Am
I gonna drown in gnome?
I think I'm gonna drown in gnomes.
No, you're a sandbox set up!
Is the room getting smaller?
I know, I think the gnomes are getting bigger.
Oh, there's too many gnomes!
I'm tired.
Wait, that was an actual ending.
I wish I had saved that for later.
Ending.
Nome.
Wait.
Wait, but, oh my...
Oh, my...
Oh, my buddy did everything.
I still have it, right?
Please...
Oh, oh my gosh, the title is now different.
Oh!
Gosh, it's gonna consume me.
Oh, he even leaves it for us.
Wait, that was so funny.
Hee!
Alright.
Let's go get the car.
Oh!
Oh, I forgot to juice it up.
Shoot, wait, hold on.
I forgot to...
Come back, I'm back.
Smoothie.
Now go back.
Wait, it's not smoothied enough.
Wait, give me, give me, give me.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Why
is it only times two?
Anyways, mountain!
Oh wait, the car is not gonna be able to...
Oh my god!
It's insanity.
Oh, there's the times five.
I feel like I didn't do a very good job with this one.
Um...
I think I messed up.
I think I messed up this blitz.
I apologize.
The car is literally floating.
how did this how did you get over here how did that happen i
shall forgive you thank you i don't know what happened to be
honest i don't know actually why it messed up so badly
that's my fault there.
10,000 stars!
City of stars are just for me.
Oh, because...
Actually, I don't know.
Excuse me!
Excuse me, please.
Excuse me, I need my star.
I need my star one.
Where is pumpkin!
Zina, what are you?
Zina, what is that?
Death?
Why is there death on you?
What does this mean?
It's a blackberry?
No, blackberries are like...
They're like raspberries.
They're puffy.
That's no blackberry.
Black current.
What is that?
Oh my god, I really just... I completely fumbled the blitz.
I'm so sorry.
We got like so little money from it.
All things considered, you know?
No!
It's poisoned.
Yeah.
Like...
Like the smoothie.
Still made over 8 million, not bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Throw that berry in the hole.
Absolutely, we will.
Oh, it won't let me.
Okay, we kind of need the berries to, like, not jump.
We need to not make money this time.
Because we are attempting...
to take the house and the buses and we kind of got to do
that without without any where where is he oh he's back to i
have to do it again okay wait wait how did you get in there
yeah my stars got refunded very very interesting
you know what i mean Yeah, I need you to push this.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, I need you to push him in there.
I need you to go this way and push him in.
Oh, no, no, just kidding.
Just kidding.
I did the wrong thing.
Come this way.
Thirm.
Hmm.
What?
Something is happening.
Nope, not something that I need to happen.
It might be too large.
No way, our hole needs to get bigger after all!
Alright, we'll abandon the house for now.
We definitely can get these, though.
The house will be our final boss.
Uh-oh.
Please.
Oh, no!
Oh!
We do need fruits to make it move.
I was such a fool.
Ugh.
Yeah, out of fuel.
I relied so much on the...
I've relied so much on it.
Like just the trampoline, you know?
Alright.
Come on.
Yeah!
Oh, we're already out of time.
That's crazy.
Crazy work.
We spent so much time trying to get the house.
Dang.
That's fine.
You love to see it.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
I want to poison the hole, though.
Maybe we'll do that this time.
I wonder if that's like a different ending.
17 million.
Anything that we're close to?
Nope.
Somebody.
Poison the water hole.
Come here, little buddy.
Alright, let's poison the hole.
What do I keep doing it?
There's like a...
Whoa.
Oh, it's starting to fill up.
Uh-oh.
You'll never take me alive!
Actually, I don't think you will.
I think I'm gonna die here.
Oh, my jetpack doesn't work.
Retreat to the gnome dimension.
Berry, burry, burry.
Yeah, the sun was crying.
Complete ending C.
So now we have two out of four.
So I'm guessing one ending will be if we get all...
Sorry, the black stars.
And one ending will be the key.
So we're about almost done with the game.
I like how the title screen changes.
It's cool.
Cool.
All right.
Send our hole over?
Well, actually, now I can like really upgrade these guys
too.
You are damn to life of...
Wait, actually, which one to snooze oh wait I don't know oh
something is happening oh geez I wasn't paying attention
okay um we need we need you to stop please please stop
please stop please stop please stop we can get it in we can
get it in come
yeah we do need to hold a grow larger though and we're quite
not there but that's okay we just got to get this in
i'll get the whole i'll get the coins so that they stop
bothering it stop bothering this bush like here like there
like right no not towards me like here
okay let's go over here and eat some stuff i don't know
Just the house left.
I wonder if collecting everything, like eating everything,
is to unlock that star.
Because otherwise I have no idea.
Unless it's like something like up here, you know, that...
There's a tape here.
This is my confession.
Oh.
Yeah, we know, girl.
I think we're aware at this point.
That's your confession, yeah.
Either I feel like finding all the tapes or...
Um, eating everything will be what...
does it.
I should start like sucking things up.
Good job.
The blitz might get me...
Yeah, that's what I'm hoping.
The next splits.
Can I get in here?
Ooh, scary.
Still, nothing has changed since we found that.
Hmm, we still have three things.
This is my confession.
That's all she said.
Things uncensored when you find black stars.
Yeah, but we only have one black star left.
Remember the star at the back?
Yeah, that's what I was talking about, that I think unlocks
when you have either all the cassette tapes
or all the stuff on the map.
So what we're going to do is we're going to start cutting
up.
Mega juicer.
D-D-Mega-Doodoo.
D-D-Mega-Juicer.
And...
Wait, what if I just do this?
Again.
Where is my smoothie?
Did I get that?
Oh, there's one over there.
What are you doing over there, do you fish?
Get in there.
It's!
And once everything stops spawning so fast...
Fountain!
The hole grows larger!
We did it!
We did it, team.
We did it, Reddit.
I feel like I didn't make so much money, though.
Oh, there it goes.
Hmm.
Big hole.
A big hole!
Oh wait, do I need more?
Okay, no, I think we're okay.
I think it'll make it.
Please, please!
Go in!
Oh!
So close.
No, this is it!
No!
This is, this is it!
Maybe?
Um...
It's still not big enough?
Why is it coming out?
Stop doing that.
No.
Oh, no, I still think.
Are you serious?
It's so close.
Maybe we need to send some fruit, knock it in there.
Oops, oh shoot, no.
Oh my God, that's so bad.
Dang.
I really thought that was our time.
I thought that was our moment One more level, I guess Maybe
level 20 truly is like The level, right?
It feels right It feels right
32 million Just got off Working Minto's still going Wowie's
out We sound much better today Thank you I probably should
go to sleep soon I'm not tired.
Alright.
We're just gonna...
Oh my god.
Don't get me.
I made a mistake.
I guess we...
I guess we don't need the trampoline if we have it right
here, though, huh?
Oh my god.
Please!
Not me!
Actually, I'm gonna take one more of my medicines real
quick.
They say not to take it too close to bedtime.
And I'm realizing it's close to bedtime.
I might be up again tonight.
Oopsie.
Okay, we're already at 55% though.
So honestly, this is going Better to plan than not.
Speed running in JST time zone.
I'm never going to get over my jet lag.
It's really tough, especially when you get sick, because
you're just like, sleep helps me recover more, so you give
into the jet lag, right?
You're like, I got to, so I can recover.
And it's like, oh no, I made a mistake.
I
don't know where the wand is.
Achieve maximum hole size!
We did it!
Where is the...
Oh, there it is.
Um, you.
What are you now?
Weenie!
You're a pair!
I don't know where the wand went.
It disappeared.
all right we'll eat it tomorrow now we'll eat it tomorrow
for real another thing up here nope i wonder though what if
it like unlocked because we achieved full size doesn't seem
like it level max baby I'm definitely not going for like
100% completion because then otherwise we would try to be
getting all the upgrades and obviously I'm not doing that
because some of them are like 100 million or whatever the
heck so we're just gonna um try and get back inside I can't
though oh my gosh I have to lead the whole way do you want a
hint for that star was both of my were both of my theories
if so yes no I didn't rewind sorry I just I just raw dogged
it
the last black star involves the wall a hole and a bit of
parkour oh okay interesting if
you're up against the wall it's okay that moves fast enough
let's see I don't think anything has changed I just Check
every time.
Yeah, all right.
Bank $100 million total.
Yeah.
Wake up.
All right, let's go get a house.
Guys, I'm going to be a homeowner.
It's time.
I'm going to be a homeowner.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes.
Oh, don't get too close.
I like how you can see, like, the smoothie.
That's why it doesn't go into the hole.
It's, like, on, like, a little ledge.
It's kind of a funny detail.
Alright.
I think we can stop the trampoline now.
She went in so easily.
Consume all props!
Burry it all where no one will ever find it is what the
achievement was called.
Crazy.
you know what I'm gonna bring the hole here
in like a bit of a corner and then I'm gonna fountain they
seem to go down almost the same time so like there
oh I probably should have juiced I just realized that's okay
I think we're pretty good on the money side of things at
this point.
In terms of, I don't think I need any more.
It was a nice scene watching it all fly.
But I think we're good in terms of buying stuff now.
Okay, so let's see.
This star.
Parkour.
How?
What, the hole?
We need the hole, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's still going.
So much money.
I'm suffering from success.
Oh, woe is me.
Woe is me.
No, please.
Where are you going?
Where are you going, please?
We're not.
We're not going to make it.
That's okay.
Woe is me.
I make too much money.
I think I need to do my unhaze.
Oh, I'm supposed to do it every four hours.
It's been five hours.
Can I do it real quick?
In my medicine, I'll have to go grab that though.
I'm not even gonna pick up all the cash.
Um, can I do like a movement speed?
Okay, hold on.
Let me do my inhaler.
Okay, I have to wait a minute.
a minute before I do another one.
And let me go get my medicine.
Okay, we're
fine.
We can do the Berry Blitz bonus growth again for the
duration.
What was the most expensive thing?
Was it this one, the 150 million?
Yeah, I think that.
We'll just finish this one, right?
And then we'll save it.
Save the money for the keep.
Go my hole.
Seek.
We might need fruits for these so we'll get other some.
To get it over there.
I don't know if we'll have enough.
Oh my god.
Me carrying two giant melons.
Crazy.
Okay, that should be good.
Oh, I made it, actually.
Impressive, Snake.
So the wall...
And parkour.
I don't see it at all.
I thought maybe, like, this part?
What?
Oh, I see it!
Wait, no, that's just the hole.
Huh?
Wait.
I'm scared.
Oh.
Can I drop?
The funky music in the background is so funny.
Oh, here we go.
Oh!
Yay!
It's like the flower of reminder time.
Oh, there it is, collect Black Star number seven.
What, uh, this coffee cup uncensored.
Oh, here we go.
I am quite the horticulturist, or at least I like to think
so.
Inside my office, hidden in the back, is an atropa
belladonna, more commonly known as deadly nightshade.
Oh.
Ingesting even a single berry.
Why am I explaining this to you?
That's what it turned into.
It's in the name.
That's what it turned into, the pumpkin.
Belladonna.
Really?
Oh, I think I'll try not to sneeze.
Or, uh...
Well, every time I think I'm going to sneeze, if I talk
about...
If I say something, then I lose it.
Belladonna berries.
Are those real?
Meeting after wrap.
Oh.
Oh, this is the day he went missing.
Seems like we'll be wrapping early today.
But I'll be around after.
I have some financials I need to look over.
If you're not busy, I'd love to chat face to face.
I want you to know that this doesn't mark the end of our
working relationship, and we'd love to keep you on board
through this transitionary period.
Please, Donna, understand that this is what is best for
Barry Patch.
Oh, yes.
Check the trash can?
There's a trash can?
I don't think I have that unlocked yet bringing in Pauline
Summers as Miss Rainbow will help bring so many more eyes on
the show and give it a fighting chance in the ratings I know
the list of changes coming next season seem extensive and
they are but I feel the true spirit of the show will still
be intact this is how you make your vision survive and last
for years to come even if it's hard to swallow in the now oh
the recycling Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes, you're right.
Um, yeah, I was going to do that.
That's why I went to the computer.
But I wanted to check the email and stuff first.
We can discuss the details tonight in person.
I know you're unhappy.
I know you're angry at me at the network heads.
I get it.
But this isn't the end for you or your career.
We want you here at Star Shine Studios.
Just not as the showrunner for Barry Patch anymore.
I've worked with you long enough to know.
And at the risk of crossing a personal boundary.
you can have a fiery temper at times I just urge you this
isn't the time to burn bridges or to kill people for what
it's worth I'm also in hot water with the network over this
looks like we're both in the same hole for the foreseeable
berry oh I can't get to it because there's a damn he
deserved it oh barry deserved it he wanted to sanitize my
show burn away my fingerprint from my own creation the show
would go on like i never existed a rewrite a recasting a
recasting of history reality no no no no i'm the director of
this story and i haven't called cut yet i'm going to bury
bury under the scorched remains of this place and no matter
how deep you dig you'll never find him i'll make sure of it
I believe there's a damn pear in my trash can.
Look, there's like a...
Oh!
There's like some other stuff in here in the lighter and
everything.
Oh my gosh, Barry.
Are you okay?
Wait, hold on.
Do any of these...
Okay, no one will find you.
Burn.txt.
Bedtime for Barry.
TXT.
Rot.txt suffer.
He deserved it.
Rot.
Pomeroy is dead.
Nobody will miss you.
There's a pair in my trash can.
Berry, no, burry dot.
Wait, it switches to burry, berry.
Oh.
Save me, gnome.
I don't like the way it looked at me.
Oh, it's so crazy.
Creepy.
Oh!
I didn't mean to do that.
The gnomes.
One, two, three.
Wait, are these 11 people?
No, these are much more than 11 people of gnomes.
Hello, little sprout.
Today, I want to talk to you about something very important.
Truth.
But it seems like you already know the truth.
I used to make this show because I wanted to teach kindness.
I wanted to help kids grow strong roots.
But then, the studio decided my roots weren't exciting
enough.
They wanted bigger flowers, louder colors, someone more
recognizable they told me it was just business I gave them
everything I had songs lessons songs years of my life Barry
said it wasn't personal she looks like a undertale it was
the studio's decision after all he lied it was Barry's idea
all along He promised me I'd still belong here.
Here in the world I created.
My world, not his.
He has his other worlds.
Popular, successful, critically acclaimed.
His legacy was intact.
His future, secure.
But what about mine?
Barry took my garden and handed it to someone else.
else.
He buried my work.
Barry, buried, buried.
Me.
He buried?
He stopped me from teaching the children how to grow.
So instead, I taught Barry Pomeroy how to rot.
So here we are, where nobody will ever find us, in this
world of my making.
No producers.
studio heads no financial reports i make the rules here but
i can't do this alone you need me to make more cash
characters friends you watched my tape and now you're here
to help create my vision for a brighter sunnier world so
we're disappointed for a person now let's get out out of
this dark hole, what do you say?
What do I say?
I could leave.
Can I get over there?
Oh.
Are you okay?
I thought we were gonna chainsaw or...
No?
We need a song for chainsawing?
Am I chainsawing now?
So there we were.
Oh, that's it?
Press any key?
Oh, a group of newfound friends seeing each other's real
faces for the first time.
And that damned tape.
We talked about telling someone.
Thank you, chainsaw man.
The police.
Barry's family.
A psychiatrist?
I feel like this is the true ending.
Maybe we should have done this one first before the key.
But we knew they wouldn't believe us.
As for the tape, we tried burning it.
Should have known that it wouldn't do it.
Took a hammer to it.
Heh, even a chainsaw.
Nothing worked.
So we dug a hole.
A deep, deep hole.
And buried it where no one would ever find it.
Seemed fitting.
We still keep in touch, even outside of our trauma support
group sessions.
It's nice having new friends.
This remake of Lollipop Chainsaw is lit.
Our counselor talked about the healing benefits of a
relaxing hobby.
Something you can really put your mind into.
She recommended gardening.
All right.
Complete ending A.
Alright, let's get the last ending now.
This one's just a normal screen again.
This chainsaw ending.
Well shoot, I feel like we should have done that one last.
But one last ending, we can just get it real fast.
Oh my god, he's still in here.
Uh, oh, I have to sleep.
The key...
To happiness.
Title for this game ended up being really clever.
Yeah, because Barry, the guy, buried the show.
Buried the Barry patch.
It's literally the title.
Yeah, and he was buried too.
Yeah, with everything, like, and then also, yeah, it's like
a double meaning, because then...
Like Miss Barry, buried, Barry the guy.
Oh, look how the berries...
Oh!
And this is where we're at.
I'm recording this in my office.
And I can't think of any reality where I get away with this.
So many questions I've had to answer, reiterating where I
was at what time, and doing what with who.
And I don't think they believe me anymore.
good of an actor as I thought.
Or maybe I'm more comfortable playing Miss Rainbow than I am
Donna Bellinger.
I don't think I'm digging myself out of this hole.
Don't cry.
You did this.
Truth, find all cassette tapes.
There he goes, the Happiness!
Lesson time!
Woohoo!
Hi there, little sprouts.
Welcome to lesson time.
Today, Miss Rainbow wants to talk about something very
important.
Something shiny.
Can you guess what it is?
That's right.
Money!
Money can buy toys and snacks and big buildings with bright
lights.
But money can't buy happiness.
I don't know.
Happiness grows on the inside, like a berry on a vine.
And if you pull too hard, well, the vine snaps.
Oh, some people forget that.
They start counting coins instead of counting smiles.
Me when they look at numbers and bottom lines instead of all
the good they could do in the world.
And sometimes they decide that if something doesn't make
enough, it doesn't deserve to grow anymore.
But gardens don't work that way.
You don't rip out the roots because the harvest was modest.
Because when greed gets hungry, it doesn't stop eating.
And when it's done, there's nothing left.
until it is done.
Vacant people.
Just take a look at our new friend, Sprouts.
And me?
What did they do?
They destroyed our beautiful garden with their insatiable
desire for more, more, more!
Never content.
Always more!
What happiness, please?
Well, if they want to be a greedy little piggy, I'm sorry I
wanted so much money!
So remember, little Sprout.
Happiness isn't something you buy.
It's something we nurture.
We were.
I'm sorry I just went to the upgrades.
I'm in my Minecraft bed.
Oh, Biggie.
Oh.
He speaks.
I mean, he looks.
He might speak.
He does not speak.
Am I the piggy?
I'm the piggy!
Greedy for coins.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Greedy for money.
Greedy for the coins.
I want upgrades.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want to...
Oink, oink.
Complete ending B.
Yippee!
27,000 berries grown.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
I only dropped 1 million.
That's pretty good, I think.
Oh, the piggy ending has him on the screen.
I wonder...
What achievements I'm missing?
Berry, berry, berry.
Let's see.
I feel like it can't be...
Oh, six of them.
one is earn nine dollars on the first day oh interesting
grow six thousand six hundred and sixty six berries have
seven pumpkin berry buddies in your garden at once unlock
all upgrades yeah bank oh my gosh i can't even read that i
think that's a billion total unlock all endings upgrades
cassettes max whole size and clear the entire map oh we
almost got that with the upgrades it's the only thing we
missed open the star door with all walls intact how
how do you even get to the star door if you don't what how
would you do that and then there's two hidden achievements
oh there's one more uh complete any ending in under an hour
mods allowed you have to use the hole in jetpack oh so like
you go into the hole and you're flying and you go under the
walls wait that's crazy that's crazy tech congrats on
getting all the endings me tell you the gray we beat it we
beat very very very there's two hidden achievements what
could they be but i got 51 out of 61 achievements 84 percent
not bad new game plus mods make it very easy to complete the
game in under an hour oh i believe it i bet now if i
restarted it would be like that'd be so fast
yeah honestly didn't think this game would have an end i i
was pleasantly surprised to find that the game had lore um
very cool very cool yeah yeah it was fun it was very
interesting to kind of it was a slow it's like i said it was
a slow start especially you only start getting the lore once
you like unlock the little castle area like the office but
um what's the lore we got i think we got most of the lore
today so that was cool yeah i like hidden stories stuff like
this so surprisingly addicting numbers go up Good job.
Hope you rest well.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
I'm gonna go eat even though it's midnight 30 for me.
I probably should have dinner and then attempt the sleep.
But I hope you guys had fun.
I did.
This was... I'm glad we could finish it and everything.
There we go.
Thank you so much for the pick.
Thank you.
you're a peach it was bananas with how much money you were
making if only we could have tossed nizzle in the hole i
know right glad the medicine has been helping hope you have
a very great night you too thank you guys i will see you
when i see you next have a good day have a good night have a
good time zone eat ata shai bye bye bye bye bye bye oh it's
a mito oh it's a mito thank you Number one, number one,
number one, number one.